what is up fam what is happening welcome
to the second calabasas fight companion
i'm here with the crew
i am with the crew to my left is mark
the body harley best body uh i'll say in
the world dude
i've had a few drinks what i'll say in
the
world zoo if there's another one dude
yeah best buddy zoo culture by far
the perennial superstar over there
coming off a huge win after a two-year
layoff i was so happy for even though
cory's my boy uh i was so happy for you
man tj dillashaw over there man looking
fresh too man thanks man yeah it does
your face is i mean you're good you look
fast your face was up good this knee
that's uh gonna take a while yeah your
leg is your leg did fall off and then we
got
josh thompson here the voice of bellator
the man the legend mma royalty over
there also won half a weighing in
podcast hey man we try to do our best
with that show it's doing well right
we're picking it up yeah you guys are
doing well man yeah i feel like we're
good i appreciate it thank you we're all
fans here uh before we get started man
we have a bunch of smooth operators
around the table tonight as you can see
and that is thanks to manscape the
official electric trimmer of the ufc
so we know we got the viewers from
around the galaxy i wish they didn't say
that whatever and your balls are pube
free it's an out of this world
experience so get your rocket ready
like jeff bezos for takeoff with
manscaped and their new lawnmower 4.0
join the 2 million men worldwide who
trusted manscape and trim with
confidence no knicks no worries get
ready for your nuts to be smooth all the
thick boys tonight get 20 off and free
shipping with the code cfc again that's
code cfc manscape.com that's 20 off and
free shipping with the code cfc
manscape.com
we got the link in code in the bio
let's get to work man so we got the
main event of the prelims on right now
uh bobby green versus
is a nightmare yeah if you know if
you're familiar with this dude he is a
technician although tonight
we said this before we went on air i
think he's reading his newspaper
clippings because i haven't seen him
fight like this i haven't seen that that
flashiness that's that that type of like
disrespect in the cage yet from him i
mean wrong he's he's nasty good i
believe he's one of the head coaches at
tiger muay thai he was out there in
thailand for a while there he's
phenomenal kickboxing man a lot of skill
i'm surprised bobby didn't start
wrestling a little bit more
yeah they
supposedly they can't you know sean
shelby couldn't find a guy to fight
fazeev like you just kind of i don't
doubt it no bobby green was like all
right they're like really okay
bobby's a stud man
tj how's the so the leg surgery went
well yeah i just had surgery on thursday
which i can't believe you're here
because i was like dude don't worry
about doing the fight you're not kidding
me i'll be there i was like hell yeah
getting out of the house bro i've been
sitting on the couch uh playing a little
bit too many video games watching tv
yeah you know what i mean saying how's
the crib yeah watch some fights with
some good company you know
you know so
let's talk about that baby face though
look at that baby face you clean up well
wife made me grow the beard out so i
don't look so young it looks good though
the scar tissues all look like you gotta
it's almost cleaned up pretty quick man
my face was up quick i had 24 stitches
in there
um i had four cuts
in four months so this eye eyes that cut
was bad man that was bad and like big
john said it that he was like it's not
like he was just like across one plane
it was like across multiple muscles and
he goes across here too yeah dude so i
thought they were going to stop to be
honest because probably worse spot to
get kind of i thought they're gonna stop
the fight and not to mention you you
blew your leg out yeah you know what i'm
saying like you got a cut you got one
leg yeah and i'm you know all within
like a minute one of his coaches lisa
bowling who's one of my best friends
who's my head coach me and him are
texting during the whole fight i'm like
dude he's doing this on one leg
yeah which were you thinking about more
money for sure oh really yeah did you
know it was blown out 100 right away so
it was like the last 10 seconds of the
round
last 30 the last 30 seconds around i was
in like a
like a lazy leg lock the guy like he had
we're in the 50 50 position i was
completely out of it but i was just kind
of like chilling you know i knew i won
the rounds was like [ __ ] sit on top
let the round finish out but then he
turned and started trying to punch me i
was like all right [ __ ] so i came back
in my own ground and pound right yep and
so i like came in hard on my own leg and
started ground and pounding and didn't
get me from the leg lock was when we got
into a scramble and he tried getting
back to his feet and i tried standing on
top so i cleaned my chest over my body
at the same time i need my lcl just went
pow and i hit it right away wow dude it
was like i'm super surprised he didn't
hear to feel it because i mean i know i
even heard it when it happened um so i
knew that i was like as soon as round
was over i went back to my corner i sat
down i was like dude my knees [ __ ] you
said that to your coach instantly that's
the first thing i said they bleeped it
out on tv because it's espn and i said
because i said [ __ ] definitely wish we
heard that i was like mine's like my
knees [ __ ] you could tell like you i
mean there's nothing as tough as you are
there's nothing you can do like me it's
not i saw i saw him looking to the
corner i was like oh that he has like a
50 50 like you said with a reverse hill
hook yeah he didn't have like he didn't
have it locked all the way up he just
kind of had it yeah i mean so it wasn't
when he had the like law cause actually
when he let go of it and he tried
scrambling up and he like threw his legs
down so he like hip thrust into it and i
tried staying on top at the same time
and it's when the lcl just went out to
the side and was it only the lcl that
blew out no i had a medial meniscus
buckle handle tear
uh lateral meniscus tear and a pcl tear
that sounds horrible yeah almost
everything i'm just glad it was an acl
like i actually
am happy with the results would have
been trouble could have been nine months
dude yeah you know like i'm looking at a
three month recovery right now until i
can get back to good training fight for
the title beginning next year but it's
not it's not i don't mean to interrupt
you it's like
you know it's not terrible because
you're not dude you're not finding next
year anyways no matter what even if you
were injury-free exactly fighting for
the title next like the only thing that
sucks is going on vacation camping
around or you know like that but
that's why i got little rascals yeah
roll around on a little scooter or
something like the fat girl at
disneyland
oh yeah eating a corn dog painkillers
which is cool
that's always fun right yeah was there a
moment during the fight where you're
like i'm gonna have to stop or at any
point like did the pain get bad i
thought they were gonna stop you're such
a goddamn savage no you beat corey
sanhagen on with one eye and one leg
this only reason why i'm somewhat happy
with the performance i go back and watch
it and i obviously was like oh my gosh
before that i watched the fight i was
like dude [ __ ] i was so sloppy i let it
i kept it way too close which if i was
close but when i go back and watch it i
definitely won the fight i agree you
know um and i know there was a a close
fight because he did damage but you
gotta remember the rounds he did his
damage in he won yeah he run like those
two rounds damaging one of them was even
close you know i almost i'm i'm biased
i'm gonna give myself four rounds right
yeah but those two rounds that he won is
when he did most of his damage in it
second and fourth the second round for
sure i came out for flat footed not a
10-8 round though no no no no because i
had i'd take down i actually thought
that too i was like there was a chance
they could have given him a 10-8 round i
was thinking about that that's the only
thing that's the only reason i'm saying
that because judges yeah idiots so i was
like i don't think so though i came
again i gave him the second and the
fourth yeah i came up super flat footed
on the second because i was so worried
about my knee when i came out he had one
liked it flat footed yeah exactly super
flat i mean i'm i'm a motion kind of guy
i'm gonna track you down i could be
honest i thought you were so [ __ ] yeah
i was like i'm like man if his legs that
bad i hope they stop it due to the cut
man i don't respect him right yeah yeah
i mean i guess frustrated um i don't
have time to be frustrated
right that's the that's the mentality of
the champion you know what i'm saying
like one eye one leg i just feel like
there was moments where i was like
another fighter would have like mentally
thrown in the towel 100 yes sometimes
but there was a lot of stuff i just
wrote him without just the knee oh yeah
it's like the i don't see them enough
yeah the higher just they'll get into a
fetal position did you did you feel any
uh you know because dominic cruz doesn't
believe in ring rush some guys don't i i
think it's real but no definitely listen
to donald cruz not me did you did you
feel any ring rust i think it's more
mental right like it could definitely be
there if you want to give yourself that
excuse um and i just want to not have
any i doubt in my mind going into that
fight the only thing is timing you know
what yeah if that was the one thing i
was gonna say so like look i thought you
looked on point i said but i felt like
you were you're only throwing ones and
twos where before you were a combination
fighter you're throwing threes and fours
finishing with a kick to the head you
know whatever was i always felt that
that was like your whole mmo before yeah
so then getting back into it you were
throwing a lot of ones and twos
occasional three but you weren't putting
it you weren't putting it all together
together
yeah it could be it could yeah very well
could be something
and he's moving right like he's got very
i already knew going to the fight it was
gonna be a frustrating thing he had a
great movement he's gonna be hard to hit
and so and then i when i busted my knee
i couldn't cover the ground i had to
keep hitting switches to try to cover
the ground you know i had to come out
southpaw
i had to fight completely different cut
them off right and like that's why in
dude if i if i would have both my legs
those takedowns when i had his back
would have been so much like i tried to
lift in the second round after i took
his back and my knee just buckled and i
was like [ __ ] man yeah that's the other
thing is he kept doing that granby roll
and giving you his back and i'm like
well that's control when you're there
like you weren't finished take down
because your leg yeah but you that's
just that's that's control man but a lot
of what i talked with big john about on
our show is the rule system and so in
terms of the scoring the control is
valued at the least in terms of like the
possession
and there's the damage in that round
it's still value but it's like here but
if the damage is here but if damage is
here the damage here and actually trying
to finish the fight though is isn't like
here if we don't even get to that next
category for sure so what they do is
they don't even actually
judge that but but they can't if they
can't if they can't say all right well
it's round two you can right but like
one three and five if you're trying to
figure out right damage pretty similar
you know then auction controls right
yeah
but then you can get to control yeah
yeah and that was tj all day yeah yeah
that's why you but normally when they
get to that though from what i
understand from talking with john about
it all is that it normally gets down to
when it gets to the damage and they both
have had damage and you both have had
like a little bit of uh submission
attempts or knock out a chance to finish
light they don't even get to control
because it really comes out of who did
the most damage and that kind of rules
the round so the damage rolls around and
don't even get to the control position
scenario but here's the thing i was like
i've told i've told john a bunch of
times
even though he's controlling it but
there was never an effort to get away so
like in one of the rounds uh was it
round three when you had the back a lot
so you were on his back and you just had
it but there was no he wasn't trying to
escape he was just cool with hanging out
with his forehead against the fence
which
which isn't good yeah which isn't good
yeah so yeah
this this fight way out punt punted his
coverage you'll by far yeah bobby bobby
bobby stephen looks like bobby was
landing a lot yeah yeah i saw him laying
on a bigger shirt yeah i think i think
bob i think bobby probably won the third
but i think he might have lost one and
two second was close it really comes out
of that he lost the first for sure
close fight though
but i honestly big john i was talking
about this on our show i was like hey
like this is not a good fight for bobby
green
not a good fight i mean i can't believe
you took it yeah he's a stud man
that's the theme about the ufc man
you know there's there's these guys and
i can't believe we take that fight but
it's the ufc dude yeah that's why it's
impossible like ufc so tough to bet on
there's no bartering though like this
decade you want this fight yeah yeah you
say yes or no that's it that's right you
see sugar shawn he on his podcast uh and
i love sugar shawn he's talking about
how
they want him to fight new york he's
like i don't fight new york dude like
taxes and yeah and he i guess his coach
can't go because his coach has 80 uh
some jutsu competition says i don't have
my head coach he said i'll just fight
like the next month or the the whenever
i start in in vegas so i don't pay all
the taxes man yeah i guess uh sean
shelby is like all right well have fun
hanging out with takashi six nine like
come on
no no same [ __ ] happen to me with with
joe silva so i i've beaten ideas right
after i've beaten ideas they call me a
little while later and they want me to
fight they say okay you're gonna fight
for pettis and i'm like all right cool
fight pettis for the title so then perez
gets injured so what do they do they
call me to fight uh this tough [ __ ]
dagger standing russian guy yeah i can't
remember i was like i was like he wasn't
even in the top 15. i'm like yeah no i'm
good man yeah i'm also i'm good he's
like well perez is out so something joe
goes well fine [ __ ] you can just sit
out for six months and so and then i
told bob i said i said look i made
plenty of money i said you can just tell
them i'm okay with waiting yeah i said
give me a top five guy i said i'll take
it give me rda rda was already matched
up i said give me somebody else give me
anybody in the top five a week later he
calls me with benson i'm like all right
cool i'll take it i told you i said i'll
take a fight if you give me somebody in
the top five like i just i'm getting
stuck i'm not getting forced into
fighting a guy who's you know not in the
top 15 or was like he was right i didn't
want to say he was ranked like number 13
or 14 or something and for you tj's is
it guarantee right guaranteed title shot
i mean yeah 100 yeah i mean i just beat
the number one contender
you know [ __ ] coming off a two and a
half year layoff you got any uh any
thoughts on al jermaine versus i think
he's me on for sure you know there's a
lot going on in that fight to first the
he yawn [ __ ] him up in the first fight
oh dude made him just quit and bow out
100 illegal knee right so that's the way
that goes but
yawn dominated the fight um sterling
just got neck surgery which i don't even
know how he's going to come back from
that anyways it's a it's a tough task
for
al james yeah so i think it's going to
be beyond the beginning of next year
yeah i agree so i agree it'll be a
little fight yeah man i'm pumped on i
think it's a really good fight for me
i'm excited for it um style matches up
perfectly for me
that is a fight
but yawn on the scene like right around
the time you were leaving for a little
bit and then yeah he wasn't even in the
ufc when i left yeah well after he was
in the ufc he wasn't even there okay he
moved up fast yeah yeah he moved up fast
i mean he had some good fights yesterday
but i've never been like i was never
blown away by him like i i would always
like kind of pick against him like all
right yeah he's cool yeah and then when
i watch the
aldo fight the uh the aldo finals dude
this guy can this guy can box yeah and
then jamaican was next like i thought al
james would be a bad matchup
no not in his wrestling but yeah dude
peter young threw him around yeah he's
got good technique man he's like his
basics are good he's meat and potatoes
yeah exactly comes forward meat and
potatoes
yeah boxing good defense he's on point
but that's i like what i know what i'm
getting you know what i mean like going
against the guy that actually has like
shitty technique but makes it work for
his style is harder to deal with than a
guy that throws what he's supposed to
throw i would say corey is tough to game
plan for 100 man corey with the knees
yeah yeah you know the darts
yeah the lane really long like just
explode one shot yeah
to be honest that was the title fight
that was like you know corey's an animal
bro he's really good i've been saying it
for a really long time i knew that fight
going into it was going to be tough but
i knew how to beat him you know and i
could have beat him a lot sound even
more soundly if i would have liked both
my legs yeah fair point you know yeah i
have no
i talked legs big john a lot about cuts
and so
the cuts that go this way like
horizontally across your face they
normally don't stop but your cut was
going up and down and so when i was
talking with him we were he's like he's
like i'm surprised because that's just
sort of getting into your in your eyelid
almost yeah
so what he says is like what happens if
the cut goes this way the doctor will
almost always stop it based on the fact
that his and get into your tear duct and
you'll have problems with your life sure
yeah and so he just so i'm surprised to
be honest after i saw especially at the
end it was almost near your eyelid dude
look i was like
right here yeah so it comes down and
then it goes across too yeah
you got that john wayne [ __ ] right there
yeah you look like a [ __ ] hockey
goalie i gotta i got from the big 60s
and [ __ ] i gotta give a big shout out to
tate tate was the cut man in the corner
um i didn't know how bad it was i knew
that i was bleeding i couldn't [ __ ]
see how to keep wiping my eye because
it's like oil in your eye right like
people don't understand like blood's
like very oily
like sweat right yeah i'd like to keep
wiping it i'd hold my hand up there like
i just like because i couldn't see yeah
you're really holding it like right
there well because i got hit with a left
hook and i think that was in the second
round too that put me to my butt it
wasn't the fact that it rocked me to
where i couldn't be on my feet but it
like hit me and i couldn't put my left
foot down because i didn't see it coming
it was like kind of like caught me off
guard you know and so after that i was
like all right [ __ ] it my hands just
stay in here you know i think for corey
too one of the reasons like you know i'm
closer with you but came up with you
know cory came to the gym when he was 16
in our gym
corey's gonna be champ it's just not his
time now like it's your time now like
for corey like he has time to it's okay
that he lost this one like he'll he'll
get there no brandon it's never okay
when you lose bro
that's sorry man
if he's fighting that but that but
that's how i made it okay for him like
yeah if he's fighting tj it's okay he
lost this one yeah he's young dude you
know was he 28 yeah that's not that
young is he 26 20 that's the prime man
20 20 26 27 to 33 is kind of your prime
32-33 and you guys were better my friend
that's right bro i mean he still got he
got what
seven more years yeah
he's twenty nine
gotcha so my my ufc career has only been
10 years you know yeah that's a long
[ __ ] you know every day right you
like yeah
yeah let's watch all the interviews
every once in a while so how good of
friends were you yeah
so
okay let's get back into this training
talk okay while we're waiting for this
uh show to start talk to him on the
train you train with him how many times
and how did it really look like look be
honest
did it go well for you what's up my man
hey
hey it's got a lot better looking in
here
good man
good i see i'm josh
my brother
what's up big dog
training was good man
brendan
you go to a place where you're gonna get
pushed yeah and i've had i've talked
about this in interviews
i've always talked about like i pumped
him up about like days i'd come home
from i come home from the gym and be
pissed because i got my ass whipped
inspired yeah you know cory's one of
those guys that would do it you know i
mean there'd be guys even less we got
watched him that i get beat by because
when i'm in [ __ ] fight camp you
should beat me
if i'm grinding
it looks like there should be me i know
i should be so worn out for sparring i'm
gonna get tired during sparring you're
gonna be fresh you know yeah that was
something that chael said i saw in a
video that like never clicked for me but
it's like this idea of like i'm in fight
camp cutting weight going extra hard
like
and i'm supposed to beat everyone's ass
i'm doing fresh i'm doing eight rounds
right and you're i'm wearing a fresh guy
in every round so you're taking a round
off and you're coming in and sparring me
yeah and i'm exhausted just from having
an eight-week fight camp you know i just
train my ass off the day before so i'm
gonna [ __ ] lose this i got the target
you're trying for me like i'm trying to
get out and if you're making healthy and
if you're not losing rounds you're in
the wrong [ __ ] spot those are the
wrong those are the
the worst type of like partners too like
i saw when i trained for nate
i had a guy who came in from hawaii his
name was rambo we called him rambo so he
came in and he would come in the last
round say in the fourth round or
whatever you come in the last round he's
like start talking [ __ ] to me come on
yeah his name's ryan come on yeah his
name's rambo it's like but with the
hawaiian accent it's like oh you
speaking pigeons yeah come on [ __ ] bro
come on it's like you like cracks i was
like [ __ ] so we just started like yeah
you just get to my my nerves right when
you have fighters you know they're not
on your level yeah and they come in when
you're not fresh yeah you've already
done two in the morning you know you've
done one workout at five i've done
another one
and you're sparring your fourth round
he's just coming in fresh like you piece
of [ __ ] you should probably introduce
our guests that just sat down
the man the myth the legend mr brian
ortega thanks coming brother
uh yeah you got a uh you got a big fight
coming up too man yeah
pretty big one title fight okanowski
uh september 25th 25th yeah it's a
little bit of time is that uh vegas they
say vegas yeah yeah all right that's a
stock card man oh yeah they got that
card the girl was fighting before that
and they got
um nick and robbie lawler yeah yeah
that's a great song
that's gonna do well pay-per-view
yeah yeah that's that's more my era
we're going
yeah i just finished training well
espn's been on my ass all day so i
showed up late oh really yeah they've
been they went to tiki's place yesterday
and then they were at the track workout
today
then
from the track i want to go pick her up
from the airport
and then uh
and then they wanted to film some more
and i'm like [ __ ] it's a lot yeah and
then now then we drive over here and and
you're coming from the ultimate fighter
like shooting fighter which is that i
don't think people realize that
especially for the coach it's it's a
beast man yeah yeah like golden fighters
a beast to shoot man yeah i didn't
realize how much work it was going to be
yeah you know what i told you you're
like you're filming non-stop and you're
talking non-stop yeah
i was like [ __ ] what does it feel like
training camp what do you think you have
on your chat bro it's not gonna get
easier
i didn't know what it would be like i
talked i talked to tj for a little bit
like hey dude like shoot me you know
like what's up but
he's right your coach lied to him but
he's
he was like bro like it's dope that you
like you'll see you're gonna make like
friendships in connection with these
guys yeah and there's just gonna be a
trip and that's all i took from the
conversation he said yeah you guys we
didn't really talk like you're gonna do
this yeah you're shooting 40 hours a day
because he was he was uh
i was
being one of those last guys in the
round for him yeah um
while he was in camp and i just remember
like hey dude i got
the call for the show how is it yeah and
he was getting ready for the first yeah
the first camp yeah the the first camp
you had with uh the guy you just fought
yeah that's right yeah yeah yeah
he's one of the guys that was pushing me
and like those how did you guys train
together
kicked a little bit yeah like i'll let
him tee off as long as i push him yeah
but not be a dick where you're like
i can go and do more because i know
you're tired
no no it's just like bro come on come on
like yeah it's all about the people i
watch the ultimate fighter i feel and i
feel like with you and volkanowski like
knowing you i know you like he would be
like playful and then you took
everything pretty personal you know
bro this i tripped out i'll tell you why
i tripped out
was because
he was shaking my hand and they said
like hey let's stir the part up mate
whatever whatever you know yeah like for
yeah for the show and i was like no like
like what sterling i'm real yeah
this is me [ __ ] like what do you mean
like stir the bottle like yeah he
doesn't know you very well i don't give
a [ __ ] like about
like i'm just here to coach this guy i
don't give a [ __ ] about trying to start
some [ __ ] with you no yeah
and then like he was all friendly then
the cameras come on and then he starts
talking [ __ ] and i just can't help but
start laughing but i look like a dick
you know like right everything he's
saying i'm just like because you know
it's not real you know
what i'm laughing at it because it's
like this is not real and then i'm like
but then like your insults are shitty
too
yeah
yeah it was cringy yeah i was like all
you can say is i was late
it was tough and then like sometimes you
would
say a little more things and then i
would get like yeah then i would get
heated yellow all right [ __ ]
like now you're using this thing to to
secretly talk some [ __ ] you could have
really
legitly like one-on-one we're behind the
stage soccer show yep
are you glad you did it though
did the show yeah yeah hell yeah it was
it was a dope experience yeah um
yeah i think it was just different
because
typically the people who do it hate each
other
yeah there's usually some people like i
didn't hate this guy there's no reason
yeah and even even then it was like
but like that's not your job right like
no you guys don't have to come up with
the animosity and like the
and like the sizzle for the show like
the ufc paired you guys together it's
like you know what you're getting
volkanovsky's good dude you're a good
dude it's like but they but they were
trying because i could tell like you had
20 cameras
and they were just you said they would
just let you stare at him like we would
stare at each other for like 20 minutes
and no one would say a word it's so
awkward so then you're like what
[ __ ] like finally
every time he like he would break first
and then say he's one of your old
trained partners yeah i'm actually never
trying to he came to alpha mill uh when
i was gone got it yeah
yeah i actually think uh song long dong
wins dude you think he wins i do casey
is the kid who is the kid who got in
trouble he's the one that got in trouble
on uh
sugar show yeah turn him out giving
heroin to kids or something like that no
no no no no
what no no no jesus
casey got in trouble because he made fun
of uh negan damn
megan anderson
oh yeah yeah but that was on that
episode
it was on that episode talking about
giving kids heroin just that they didn't
care ufc was like hey
yeah whatever man [ __ ] that you can't
make fun of me yeah
yeah did they though he was still on the
card right because then he fought uh
cruz yeah he fought dom yeah and he lost
he had a close fight split decision was
this with decision
yeah i thought dom won though i'm on it
it's close but i thought i got more i
don't want to so one of the comments
here i just wanted to check him was ask
ortega what he thinks about brendan's
black belt promotion
oh yeah
yeah yeah we gotta roll find out
i used to have to roll this dude all the
time yeah i was like what was like 20
years old and [ __ ] we're just rolling
yeah it was fun though and i knew i
would never take him down but i was
still shooting anyways and he [ __ ]
just sprawled me back he's trying to
[ __ ] and he would just laugh and i'm
gonna [ __ ] like i'm gonna get a take
down and i would go again and you're
just like blam myself how much do you
walk around with tenacious 165. oh
that's so he's like 170 the heaviest
yeah like at that point i was like 165
the heaviest yeah but then he would go
from me to the other dudes and me and
henry just sit back and watch him just
[ __ ] triangle after triangle triangle
yeah i was still i was still trying
though yeah yeah
i love seeing henry on the ultimate
fighter too man it was yeah people don't
realize how good about how good of a
coach
you dude
even just like the couple practices that
came to your guys's and stuff and just
like watching the way he was coaching
you and the positions he sees and the
way he breaks things down like he's a
very good coach he sees [ __ ] that's like
yeah he sees he's really good
he's got just those quick little like
darts chokes you showing off the wall
and stuff like yeah you're gonna stick
with me forever that's so scary yeah
he's an umbrella he's good yeah so good
the good thing i like he's always
cooking something new yeah yeah it's not
like a a coach who
has
dive into foot locks for like he
literally will devote three four years
of his life to foot locks yeah
especially and then he'll go i have this
master from escapes to sweeps like he
masters it in a bunch of different
things and goes okay now i'm going to
shoot to arm locks yeah now i'm going to
shoot into taking the back
and now i'm going to shoot into
it seems like an aspect of mma that just
rewards creativity like eddie bravo and
then with him it's like i'm always next
to him so
even if i don't want to learn and i'm
going to have to learn it anyways yeah
because sometimes he's like he was in
the footlocker and i'm like [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then he broke my foot and i'm like
well [ __ ] it
yeah yeah
this [ __ ] works
do you look for foot locks and leg locks
when you're not really no not really
especially with fights i don't think uh
unless you're a master at a foot lock
yeah even i look at it i don't look at
ryan hall yeah i don't think you should
be going for foot locks in an mma right
dicey i feel like footlocks should be
used as a position to put fear into them
and use it as a sweep as a result
yeah
versus
trying to get stuck there and finishing
while you get punched right
you know because if you're one you
mentioned
if you dive in there you're trying to
figure it out
yeah yeah that's with foot locks with
leg locks and foot locks it's one of
those you attack as fast as you can if
you don't get it you use it to get back
on top yeah if once you don't get it get
out get it i'll put a fear in you and
then once you run i use that as a sweep
and now get on top yeah but it's more a
sweep than it is yeah an actual
submission we're not trying to hang out
there what was the guy that uh frank mir
did that against uh
[ __ ] talk about leglock yeah frank muir
did it against somebody a long while
brock lesnar no somebody else
thing for the fight so he did the fight
and it was able to finish and he was
frank he finished frank because hammer
fisted him because frank kept trying to
hit the leg up to it you squished him in
and just [ __ ] hammer fisted him
knocked him out yeah yeah
this is water if you want a water yes
she's just watercolor i know it looks it
looks like a tall boy but it's water
yeah that was beard liquid
yeah chappelle's got one of these every
morning when we when he picks me up yeah
and i love him
yeah brian looked at it like uh what are
you giving me probably it's like i'm a
camera i was like roman canvas
seven after this weekend i think yeah
yeah still a long camp yeah you got a
long camp i'm already [ __ ] i feel great
already you look great that last night
like uh you can't you're you knew camp
too from previous yeah from everything
yeah it was
hannah's only one stayed
yeah if he would have got rid of henry
we had been
we would have been questioning your
choices yeah no i would have lost but we
wouldn't have fought
no you big [ __ ]
i can run faster
how's that jeep doing man
it's dope
yeah it's dope do you get hooked up
because uh
you know i get my car hooked up like
tuned and stuff like that do they take
care of you or everything it has a
supercharged like
yeah it's insane have you seen his have
you seen this jeep oh it's not insane
bringing us [ __ ] up
it's the most insane jeep you've ever
put a supercharger on it from these guys
at craftworks [ __ ]
they just saw my jeep and they just
souped it all the way up did they see it
like came in it's even better than that
that's when it was on street wheels not
having legit on like uh is on your
instagram right now yeah like monster
trucker ones yeah i have like real like
real beat locks like 40 inch tires like
you're taking a wheel in yet [ __ ] yeah
dude that thing is insane but with those
giant tires it can't be too fast right
bro it has a supercharger
tires are [ __ ] loud like as long as
you have the axles down right that way
you don't have like it's made out of
gears too you just gotta lower the gears
on it yeah yeah the guy i don't think i
have on my social you know what maybe
down back in the down a little bit like
burned down l.a after the final october
i have like a photo of that with like
the impala that that i have and i did
like a little cool la and they just
shoot oh there's that one
yeah that's when they supercharged it
that thing looks nuts
yeah actually does donuts like legit
burnouts and they just say hey leave it
with us and we'll we'll hook it up yeah
my homie uh so check this there you go
geez that thing's nuts
so
my homie the guy who who did the jeep
he used to work out of a garage and was
like a jeep nerd
like just
dove in like
jeeps yeah yeah
and i was like i saw what he did to my
car initially initially and i was like
cool
i got like 10 15 friends that are
that's on my jeep and they got jealous
so they're right the same [ __ ] yeah yeah
can you do it and he's like oh [ __ ]
that's a lot of work okay
he's like [ __ ] you don't make money or
not yeah yeah right
and uh it went from like a hobby to his
and then now he has a shop
oh damn it legit business
they're like bro we're in a [ __ ]
pandemic you want to make money or not
yeah like come on does he have one of
those bumper stickers says it's a jeep
thing you wouldn't understand no
yeah you ever seen those it's like
yeah i've gone to some little courses
they have they'll set they'll go like
like a bull arena
and they'll set
like man-made courses that's designed to
flip you and like
get you stuck and everything and oh nice
they dropped you in there and like and i
threw my thing in there and i actually
passed the test oh
no i'm like but i was a shitty driver
the guys were like oh yeah i just want
to go fast man
you're a porsche guy oh yeah dad's out
there that monster's out there did you
drive the jeep
yeah i took my dad's jeep over here all
right it's uh
yeah type move because uh someone's
gonna keep my jeep right now
someone someone someone has my jeep for
camp right now uh not a bad gig driving
thing around
uh this is the first five main car we
have a clicker up anyways though right
so people know where we're at yeah
you got this guy tj yeah i think song
dong is going to win i think he's uh
underdog though i know i think he's a
tank bro he's a hard hitter and like i
know like he [ __ ]
uh yeah cheetos beat him they like so
dong seong won but uh i think cheeto
should have won the fight
um but this casey kinney guy like he did
a good job against cruz but i don't
think he's got enough like power to
we'll see i just don't think he's got
enough pop in his shots
the thing what song you know like is
that his name
i'm saying song
you know something we don't know
what's going on possibly
he leaves himself open to be hit quite a
bit
he has that very kind of straight up and
down
stand up
he's got power though any predictions
for a main event i have i have a weird
feel as the night gets closer i feel
like derrick lewis is going to win yep i
i feel the same way wait i've been pre
i've been on serial guns nuts for the
past months
because footwork's so good he shouldn't
be the favorite he's not athletic he
doesn't get hit he never gets hit i'm
dude he's very
they had like four swipes and they were
all like mini videos of them sparring
and they're going pretty hard oh [ __ ]
this guy's good i know yeah he's [ __ ]
good i was like he's so athletic bro
he's gonna be so aware of derek
derrick
oh [ __ ] yeah he's nasty he's just so
athletic and like his technique's insane
for a heavyweight
the problem with him is if he if he does
win you're gonna get five round boring
decisions yeah like he's not a really
exciting fighter he doesn't knock
anybody out he's just technical he's
super technical doesn't get hit just
wins rounds well especially if you're
playing ufc he's like dear god don't win
if you're fighting a guy that's got
power in your hands you have to fight
that way right like you got to fight to
an extent of being smart keep your
distance move i think he fought
rosenstein hits i mean obviously it's
probably francis derrick lewis 1a1b then
rose street's probably second in that
division as far as hitting hard
roadstreak didn't [ __ ] touch a man
but it wasn't a fun fight but you gotta
look at derrick uh derrick lewis and
ghana remember when they fought the
worst fight the worst fighter straight
times
but i think if they if they do fight
again it would be different yeah they'll
feel the pressure and someone's just
like alright [ __ ] it let's just get in
the face do you see that meme where it
was like
gone like superior boxing
kickboxing grappling conditioning
everything that being said derek lewis
round three tql yeah that's where i'm at
that's right all week i was giving god
all this stuff and then this morning i
woke up like oh derek lewis gonna knock
him out in his hometown yeah
and apparently like he he has been
training i saw some of his coaches
talking derrick like they're like he's
i've never seen him he's taking a
serious yeah
i mean dude if you're changing [ __ ] up
like
i don't know maybe no
because he's obviously training harder
because there's that much more pressure
on him he's not just training just
because right it's like
he's that much more nervous about
getting this title no
i might say
when did he come on below the belt years
ago remember when i was doing the tv
show downtown yeah during the tv show
was that four years ago
maybe three four three four years ago he
was there and it was uh
either after i forget what it was but he
was just basically like yeah i'm done
man that's he said i'm sick of my kids
making fun of me when i lose he was like
there's like all these kids yeah i'm
thinking they're making fun when i lose
i'm just sick of this [ __ ] i was like
dad you can't be done dog and then the
ufc must have threw him [ __ ] stacks
because then he signed a six-fight deal
like that next monday so
yeah he's taking seriously he got really
frustrated after he lost to dc he just
was like conditioning cardi because that
was for the title that's right that was
for the heavyweights yeah that was for
the heavyweight title so
that's when he started actually getting
in better shape his conditions are
getting better his last two feet lost a
lot of weight not just losing the weight
but his last two fights in the third
round he's the one pushing forward
yeah and if he gets on top of you i
would i can't imagine more handsome yeah
too really really he is he is very very
very noticeable
yeah
you see that video of him and his kid on
the four-wheeler no no on his uh
instagram there's like him and his kid
on the four wheelers he played on fire
in the kid remember yeah and actually
all that's right and his and his kid
grabbed the throttle yeah it was in gear
he saved them
[ __ ] ran right into the house
yeah jeff ernest
i feel like he has pressure now for his
post-fighting ideas and they're not as
good because before it was so organic it
was him yeah and then now i feel he
feels the pressure yeah like every every
time he's like i take a [ __ ] man like
you use that last time right yeah yeah
the balls was hot was this all-time like
unexpected great balls is hot
greatest one ever
i like that i gotta go doodoo yeah yeah
he's so funny man
yeah if he wins he sets the so set the
record for most knockouts ever and
you'll see history so you have to dude
if he wins it's going to be so good for
the ufc yeah because you do him for
francis it'll get francis out of you
know whatever he's dealing with and
they're talking about john john verstipe
apparently stephen accepted the fight
there's waiting on john mm-hmm johnny
gonna accept it
so i think he should get his beak wet
had heavyweight fight you know arguably
the greatest heavyweight at all time in
the fc he won't fight unless he gets
paid though yeah and they don't want to
give him the money yeah
hopefully they do he's looking thick
but like in a good way in a good way
yeah
he's doing all that speed training and
[ __ ] too though he looks [ __ ] good
here's my thing too about john i used to
train with a man and he he wouldn't go
with like middleweights and light
heavyweights it'd be like me alice
drovering travis brown like those were
his rounds
big guys andre arlovski yeah it was all
heavyweights yeah [ __ ] up everybody
that was back then yeah when he's coming
late like that's interesting it's not
gonna be a problem for him oh there you
are brian
well how many i've got was this long
season ever i've been watching i've been
trying to keep up with it yeah
is it 19 episodes
yeah
i put it this way
and i'm not like
i don't even [ __ ] watch the whole
show why would you you went through it
i watched two what do we watch three
episodes three episodes together and i
haven't watched [ __ ] since yeah yeah
like i know everything that happened i
talked to the guys yeah you know what's
going on uh
yeah
and then a lot of things that happened
like i'm like [ __ ] like the way
they got to make a reality show like a
lot of gold
is lit at least in my opinion like gold
things that happened
fit the narrative like you know what we
did that okay so we did the uh i think
they just i saw because you see like the
weekly updates on something on social
media at least i kind of have an idea
where they are
they did a challenge where
they changed the tires for a car
so
like nascar style like this yeah
like on a like a baja like oh 1000 yeah
yeah
and uh sure enough like we like we lost
that challenge
but me and tiki took off in my car in
the jeep
and then the guy took off too and like
we took off across the street from that
lot
and we started just
[ __ ] made like we're doing donuts
together like that's cool and like some
crazy [ __ ] was like
we unleash hell on that dirt that dirt
like yeah so we're like the guy working
for the ufc team called like the cops or
whatever like what the hell
security was
cause you know why ufc can hear that
right
yeah yeah because it [ __ ] looks
recognized because
like you're playing as you but it was
like
but it happened
you know the plan is for you to beat
volkowski and they can't have you like
this crazy [ __ ] daredevil i don't
know bro it's something
yeah that's true it does but it doesn't
fit brian you know it's like brian's a
stand-up you know what i'm saying but i
loved the fun [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah it is weird with ultimate product
because you remember there there's
producers so it's basically real world
cage fighting and they still gotta put a
whole new dude there's like if you would
have got hurt it would have been our ass
and then i was like
but did you die like yeah yeah did you
die
then donald 5000 is like yeah i did yeah
right yeah
in the ambulance
it's actually crazy how much they can
switch up
when they film it that you i think it's
going to go exactly how it was filmed
they'll switch the order of fights
they'll [ __ ] they'll switch their
interviews
not sure exactly those they'll show
weird stuff like on my season where i
knew like i thought it was just all
right this is a competition that's what
it is yeah and then
rashad and i were training partners but
rashad was my coach so
the when they were making the fights i
went after a shot i was like hey i
sparred with kimbo i will and i wasn't
friends with kim about time i was like i
will [ __ ] destroy that dude give me
him i'll submit in 30 seconds rashad's
like bet that's the fight i'm like hell
yeah fighting kimbo it's getting so many
views
i was like couldn't sleep the night
before next morning
they go to do the announcements and uh
dana's like it's roy nelson versus uh
kimbo i get in the back i'm like what's
up what the [ __ ] he's like
call from the from the top dude that
wasn't the fight they wanted to get a
red phone call yeah i was like what he's
like all right
that's when i realized i'm like oh i'm
on this isn't i'm on a reality show
that's what's going on here yeah yeah
they did not want kimbo to succeed yeah
damn
so he gave him the worst possible
matchup yeah
a black belt who has
former world champion with 30 fights
like and kimbo has no ground game you
know what i'm saying so it's just like
worst case scenario for him
shitty deal for him
but then there was also some guys who
were like yeah man the way they edit i
look like an ass i'm like oh dude you
know you're an [ __ ] yeah you didn't
know that you didn't oh you didn't know
that no no that's how you that's how you
talk but like you know
i was like
you're the guy saying that yeah dude
there's you know
like [ __ ]
yeah it's like oh no you're just an
[ __ ] until you see the show it's like
guys say that all the time whoa
i just gave up and i just know i'm an
[ __ ]
but you might be in that environment
like that's not a real environment dude
you're there against
your will world champion yeah you're
there you know you gotta do a job like
that's not the real brian ortega like
you're there the guy you're gonna fight
soon is that you know what i'm saying
it's like it's heightened [ __ ]
it's tough yeah it's weird maybe an
[ __ ] yeah
maybe i [ __ ] i don't know now i don't
think henry let you become an [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying
yeah henry was trying to stop me like
from certain ideas that i had yeah but
he was like don't do that
such as for example
just
just a situation that i was like all
right this guy actually what else i bro
i don't give a [ __ ] i go i'm gonna swing
on someone probably like
but yeah because yeah because i don't
want to like
yeah
but it's like like even even for you
when you slapped uh korean zombies
manager who's uh
[Laughter]
chin's friends with him and chin was
like can you believe ryan did that i'll
go [ __ ] yeah like right
stop talking
is he not his manager he just deals with
his social media you don't have to talk
about it
yeah it was
knowing you like that was out of
character if you had any idea of what my
week was like that week you would
understand like stress just sit like
i don't know if tikki's getting mad if i
speak right now
who's getting it
but that provides some context that we
didn't know like you know hey put it
this way i got in a fight
i got in a fight on a friday
some crazy [ __ ] happened on a thursday
so you're just i was on a bomb on that
one and then you saw him yeah and i
wasn't getting in trouble like to the
point where like it's like
some [ __ ] happened uh
in vegas and [ __ ]
like right the friday before that fight
got in
got in a fight
uh
[ __ ] cops had had us like belly down
and [ __ ] and the guy looks at me like
brian like what the [ __ ] say [ __ ] do you
know
what are you doing
bro
[ __ ] jump bro like yeah yeah they
don't like that oh yeah i think it's
like my homies getting jumped so i'm
gonna help them out i just i can't think
i just gotta act right i'm like oh my
career like i see you again i see four
guys on you that have something yeah we
are uh trained not to think yeah i mean
like you think you lose but then when
you unleash that [ __ ] inside of you and
you then you see the aftermath you're
like
cops don't see [ __ ]
happened
for guys
it shows that they're all [ __ ] asleep
someone's [ __ ] hitting guys just so
good
triangle
but the cops saw me let me go which was
good nice and then
uh
yeah i was already see not all cops guys
not all cops
and uh
so yeah and then i [ __ ]
told the homeboy if i saw him i'd slap
him
yeah
because he was controlling his social
media right he was at the end like when
i talked to korean zombies said he
wasn't whatever i think it was just a
misunderstanding misunderstanding i
don't know i like that i like yeah i
like those guys but i just felt like bro
like in my opinion was like just stay
out of it like the fight's already
happening
we're not getting pay-per-view buyers
like i went to korea i showed nothing
but love over there i was respectful
even when he told me like hey dude it
was my team yep and i said [ __ ] like it
is like [ __ ] it bro like just yeah we
don't have to be [ __ ] every fight
to each other to promote it
like i think we're two good fighters
it's not gonna be it's not your nature
it's not natural for you so when this
little guy like when this guy starts
kind of acting up on social media and
like kind of
like in my
the way i took it was like he's kind of
puffing his chest i'm like hold up
[ __ ] like you're not a regular
guy he's a rapper where
where uh
like if someone talks [ __ ] okay but it's
like bro we're we're gonna run into each
other yeah i'm gonna see you yeah it's
not like something inside yeah and it's
like i'm and i'm nice with everyone yeah
i don't have issues with anyone rather
than even volcanos whatever like i don't
have issues with anyone yeah
so i was like bro just stop that [ __ ]
and he still kind of kept fighting all
right [ __ ] like
yeah wait till i see you yeah
and then i
i didn't even know he was there until
like i looked back and i was like
[ __ ] he's there
i swear that's what ran through my head
i was like [ __ ] like i'm been already in
the world of [ __ ] from this week we're
like well i guess i get a slap and
that's what i told myself [ __ ] dude
and i walked up like i jumped over the
chair and i was just like look i don't
want to do this and i still didn't
realize i still didn't even i wasn't
even sure if it was him or not yeah and
i said hey [ __ ] what's your
[ __ ] name korean people no no
you have to ask his name i was just like
hey [ __ ] what's your name yeah
if you would be like hey bro
relax
i want to [ __ ] did [ __ ] yeah but what
i want to do but he was just like
like he was like oh like jay park like
the way he said i go oh yeah
[ __ ] like all right
and then it was like
[ __ ] all right that just happened
but if you're gonna do it's probably the
best place to do it yeah the ufc was
like okay let's get them out
oh no not the best place bro oh really
[ __ ] you know what happened did they
beat you up in the back
i got taken to the back
and then another liquid death
i thought it was like whatever something
happens it is what it is yeah well
they're all still yours well now they're
like hey dude you have to like you have
to sit here and wait if they're gonna
press charges you're not in this and
then i was like
and then all of a sudden i'm like [ __ ]
yeah like all right now i'm stuck here
now if the cops come and they have me
they're all silly and then they're like
uh who press charges though too you know
what i'm saying put it this way
they said no one's present charges get
the [ __ ] out of here i'll go to my homie
suite
security starts coming i'm like
you're like where you guys doing
this [ __ ] don't look right yeah i
thought we were good so i was like hey
bro
could be a solid like what's the [ __ ]
going on yeah they're like cops are on
their way to the rescue uh he's pressing
charges now ah
that's kind of did he really do that
that's a [ __ ] no no no okay at that
time at the time he thought about it
because i was just like [ __ ] i go no
that's not cool oh come on bro i didn't
[ __ ] you slap by the way you didn't
do it joe shilling no
and uh what grown man president charges
though come on
that's what i was doing press charges
well i had a [ __ ] fleet of t-mobile
arena like hiding out from the cops and
[ __ ] crazy and the [ __ ] security like
high spri i had to put the security like
yo do me like solid get the [ __ ] out the
door like move out the way homie you
never saw me like they were cool brian
brown i was like how many [ __ ] years
have i known you come on i was like just
do me that favorite thank you for the
main event here in two weeks i was like
they come over here you didn't see me
that's it like i want to take a shower
or whatever
and [ __ ]
all worked out man and took off and then
the bad the reason why that's bad is
because he could have sued me and the
ufc
because i threatened him already
and knowing like they were supposed to
take care of him well because it was
pre-meditated like you yeah it was like
yeah so
ufc security whatever could have got
sued uh i could have got i was gonna get
sued
um
i mean who sues these days and then uh
everyone i i found myself in a situation
like [ __ ] went to a fight and a fight
broke out what the [ __ ] happened
koreans are very litigious but about
wait what what's his name again
jay park or
jay park jay park yeah and i like jay
park but it's but it's also like that's
like that's the game you're playing
right exactly if you talk [ __ ] to brian
ortega and then you come to a ufc event
that brian's at and brian say he's going
to slap you will keep that same energy
when he see him even though he's a good
guy
but he was getting his homies
out of the window he was going he's
getting his homies he said there was a
misunderstanding too it wasn't even him
on the texting that's there's just a
misunderstanding right but the whole
thing where if he's acting tough it
might be funny everything at the end of
the day was all just bad communication
yeah i have a question though who said
who sat you guys next to each other no
let me
this day is unclear bro let me tell you
something
the second i get there i never even saw
homeboy yeah i put that up on everything
i love my kids everything i go i go in
there and the second i get there if you
look up uh korean zombies footage
literally as i walk by his wife's
already filming me uh
his wife's like this
and i'm like [ __ ] like one i won't ever
[ __ ] fight a guy with his wife there
out of respect why for kids
i'll catch you later yeah wait in the
tally mafia
i mean i feel like that's respect
so and then i and i walk and i say hi to
i think it was a dan i say hi to dan
bilzerian he was there i was partying
with him like on a thursday night
uh say what's up to a couple people
and then um
i look over and she's still filming me i
go okay now they're in my opinion i go
they're trying to poke me like poke the
bear yeah but like why do that
i go all right cool
and then [ __ ] it who's with you hannah's
not i have one guy named julian with me
one of my agents
and then i'm chilling
and uh
i see i see him get up and leave
and i'm like
i'm looking i'm looking i'm like all
right like
whatever
and i look over at this chair and i
start like playing these fake like these
thoughts in my head like
but if i was to run at him
scenarios yeah like i'm going through
scenarios in my head
and then jj was going to uh the girl
from china yeah
everyone starts standing up and i'm
sitting and i look over at his chair
still like
and then it's empty the chair is empty
but i'm still like my [ __ ] mind's in
like a different state if he was there
and then i look in the throat behind him
and everyone's standing up except this
one guy
and he looked a little bit fidgety
it's like [ __ ] i'm gonna get slapped no
and then i went like that
in my head i go
that's that [ __ ] look like i had
a vibe i go that's him
and i go yo julian do me a favor i have
no service here
look up that guy jake uh or
jay parker please
what ago
i have a i think that's him
i go can you please look him up
he looks him up i go to his uh his uh
social media
did you see him start zooming in on the
tattoos he has
i go bro i can't tell but i think those
are the same tattoos it's a match
i go it's closer to 48. it's like it's
close enough if i go [ __ ] it it's closer
you got the same tattoos as the dude
i gave him the phone and i just jumped
over
and i [ __ ] and that's why i asked i
go hey what's your name only like yeah
what the [ __ ] your name yeah if you
would have said something outside he's
like jake perk
i'm not trying to say that but [ __ ] it
like you know that's what it was and it
happened but at least it's over with me
it's over with but and when we talked
about the show we kept saying like
there's no way it's looking sick what
were you saying that's roger clemens oh
well we talked about the show we kept
saying like that's not brian
yeah that's not right at all that's not
his character we just kept saying that
he's there but he's wrong the thing is
like maybe you say that it's not like i
said it on interviews like yeah i've
literally set out interviews if you piss
me off to the point where i'm like man
[ __ ] you
like
it's for real but if it got but if
there's a reason for it so that there's
a reason for it at that point you
wouldn't just do it you just not just
randomly hit something yeah people
thought like i was trying to hype to
fight or whatever i didn't think that
or some people were like why brian
stupid why would he do that picking on
the innocent part like i got so much
[ __ ] from it dude like it was crazy but
then all that squash once you guys fight
well like where i come from at least
what we're taught to like if you can't
[ __ ]
if there's beef between people you shut
the [ __ ] up yes you don't get involved
and if you get if you get involved
there's repercussions you might like
some [ __ ] might happen yeah yeah and uh
although we are professionals and
everything like this we're also fighters
bro like yeah especially and people
forget people forget what god is yeah
what's like
you know what god is fighting
and having jobs is fighting correct like
at least for me like i [ __ ] my entire
life yep street well mm whatever it was
like we would always fight yeah we
didn't like each other the way we
settled it is like we knuckle up and
that's it did you see the joe schilling
thing the guy was like talking [ __ ] to
him talking [ __ ] to him and then you
know joe schilling does what joe
schilling does knock them out
and everyone wants to be up in arms
about like but also like that drunk guy
talking [ __ ] joe schilling's like
that's what happens dude yeah like if
you talk [ __ ] someone there's gonna be
some reaper did you forget we're not on
facebook right now [ __ ] that's
like really when it comes out
like people talk [ __ ] to me online and i
just always have to i'm like you know i
bet you like a thousand bucks you
wouldn't say that to my face yeah
but it just is the case obviously with
fighters even more so it's like people
are it's like i'm a professional fighter
and you're gonna you're gonna talk [ __ ]
to me like you know me especially joe
schilling though it's like he's smoking
cigarettes he has his [ __ ] ears it's
like dude world-class striker it's like
what do you think is going to happen
people are out of touch with reality
exactly well that guy got a dose of
reality i mean
no yeah it's just it's it's weird bro
i'm glad that this is weird
i had to wait a year and i just i don't
apologize actually that's the only way
he didn't press charges
he was like he was like dear jay you
know you know this shit's fake right you
know she's fake i'm not apologizing but
he was like it took me three apologies
because i was [ __ ] stubborn yeah yeah
but here's a thing i literally was
but you're still a businessman at the
end of the day and i and
one thousand percent yes and i [ __ ] up
and i forget sometimes or or
like i said that week like i have i'll
show you after this like
i'll show you the [ __ ] bar fight i
had i'll show you like
the other [ __ ] like that's not going to
happen
let's not do that anymore yeah let's not
do that no the security the security
sent me the the footage
yeah
no no the security sent me the footage
that's it
you make a ton of money to fight stop
fighting outside of the cage stop let me
just stop let me tell you all right
let me tell you way back
i know i might sound like i have excuses
after excuses but listen
my hum
my cousin right mm-hmm uh
he was drunk hey now this can get you in
trouble right tell me stories all right
i hope not i don't need you to travel no
that happened that happened okay good i
don't want to eat my cousin
long story short
that's my [ __ ] writer though your
cousin yeah sure he's like he he got out
he did eight years okay like that
[ __ ] got mad love for me yeah
it's a long time um
he hits me up 24 hours is a long time by
the way yeah and that's my good channel
yeah yeah and uh
so he's out he's about you know like i'm
taking care of him watching over him and
[ __ ]
uh
he got he started drinking but he wasn't
drunk
he was just drinking but i know he's
driving and he's up the street from my
house i said hey bro i'm gonna go pick
you up
i'm gonna take you home like you don't
need to get dui and and and break uh
parole or anything on some stupid [ __ ]
yeah hashtag good guy yeah don't get
don't get a gear bullet yeah for some
stupid [ __ ] yeah
and to me i go i'm two miles from where
you're at it's nothing to me just come
to my house and just
sleep over here
i literally walk in
i shake his hand
and then the drink spills on someone's
jeans this at a bar yeah okay i say my
bad bro but the guy had [ __ ] with him
and then i go hey bro let me like let me
buy you a drink he's like not flat oh no
like bro let me buy you and your homies
a drink like like and he still wasn't
having it and he he got up and then
finally just can your cousin fight
you do eight years you leave me no
choice you never know you're doing eight
years and glad you're here
you know i know he's drunk but yeah
eight years you either you know no he
could be a guy hold a pocket he's a
gladiator no no he's uh
no no you don't have to present
is actually one of my favorite lesbian
fighters in the ufc
top three at least top three
[Laughter]
she's a badass though i think angela
hill beats her though
this time around you think so yeah yeah
she's not she's underdogs she she
doesn't do well with what she's like if
she can't get you yeah like if you know
yeah she's good
yeah she's just the decisions never go
her way
i get to pee so hard i'm trying to be
like rogan where he doesn't peter in
shows but i'm just not joe rogan
but we're also drinking whiskey during
the show so does he though dude he's
having a camel he can hold it for four
hours damn
i know i try to be like him that's why
he makes the big bucks you're right you
know what i mean like 0.02 what he makes
you guys hold the fourth down
i'm sorry hey have you noticed though he
[ __ ] he doesn't talk about his
contract at all he doesn't talk about
his deal at all people try to hit him up
on his show about it
no i know i get what you're saying but
but it's kind of already been out there
i'm sure not the details been up there
but i think people try to get him hey
man i [ __ ] yeah but you don't hear a
great job when you're that can get in
the new car he's like yeah okay you
don't want to try it
at all but yeah he doesn't want to make
the show about him and that's how
successful he is yeah but it's all same
with like you know
nfl player or baseball player signs a
new deal or like brian like once he
beats volkanowski let's say he signs a
huge deal yeah you know i'm not gonna
bring it up on here dude six fights
[ __ ] hundred million what i mean like
yo [ __ ] guess what i just made
legit tries to change the conversation
to something else yeah so it's awesome
it's awkward for me yeah i know people
like that because you feel like it's
unreal but it's also like it's kind of
yeah i mean it's just the world we live
it's kind of unfair like it'd be great
if like that number if spotify just went
like yeah we signed rogan you know
everyone's like yeah damn i wonder how
much you made but it's like yeah we
signed rogan 100 mills god damn why you
gotta throw that out there yeah yeah
yeah you know what i'm saying
yeah but you can't argue he's the most
influential person of our time right now
dude yeah
he's well by far yeah he's the male
oprah you know what i'm saying
remember when she would just be like hey
this book's good and the book would
[ __ ] sell jacob
that's how rogan is you go on there and
say anything about anything and it sells
out yeah yeah yeah yeah she's got her
she if el can go extinct it's gonna be
trying to start her own network and
didn't work oprah yeah yeah she's worth
like damn near a billion dollars how
much is oprah worth jen i think more
than rogues yeah the richest girl the
richest female in the royal right now is
the girl that did the harry potter books
wrong oh who is it now the lady who
divorced [ __ ] oh bill gates jeff bezos
if you want to narrow it down to none is
it is it here it's her she's the richest
female in the world okay okay like 53.
that makes yeah that makes sense because
what's her name is also uh steve jobs
narrow it down to people who earned
their own ex-wife she's worth uh
not more than she was basically she's
worth she's worth 50 million though jeff
bezos broke up with his wife and then
got this girl with a crooked eye it's
pretty cool i'm gonna take this yeah
i love crooked eyes
i love crooked eyes
is there any comments mark any good ones
good ones
what's your idea we didn't read comments
on this page i thought we interviewed
this is a thing now
you know let's see all right man i'm not
gonna lie i got a little crush on this
girl she's hot she's she's so cute like
she's just she fights hard she comes out
aggressive
here's a funny one surprised mark didn't
use his ass cheeks to pick the ice out
okay all right yes i like that one
it's cause he's got him
[Laughter]
normally i would
who wins
now that you're here at the table who
wins
who wins female fighters let's go uh
who is it hillary clinton
yeah
okay put that aside though
she can't i can't you can't do that
that's that's the friend right there
no i feel like i this is how i feel i
feel like the first fight was a good
fight yeah i think that teaches got a
lot better but so is angela anne's got a
lot better she's a lot more confident in
what she throws out yeah she's and i
think that you'll be training it and
you're like okay yeah her output though
her output is a lot more than when they
when they fought the first time
uh i seen her like with with the janet
from like the one one champion okay and
that one girl um jackie
i don't want to miss
from ufc or she she's they're both from
one oh from one but they're just like
these stand-up girls or
uh
is it uh one champion the female girl
there yeah they they're talking about a
place called boxing works yeah yeah
angela's been training
her goal with her and she trained with
them i saw that she was there that's her
girl in the back right just guy is that
right no
kel pennington raquel pennington yeah
right she's from colorado too i should
know that somebody asked me who's my
favorite gay fighter in the ufc i don't
know
do you know any brandon fighters
he's like [ __ ] you man
yeah i don't think there's anything
that's uh come out
just statistically though brian's like
volkanovsky
[Laughter]
yeah i'll never forget when i was
playing college football my uh
my coach goes i don't know why i said
this we're in the middle of cambodia
statistically
one in eight men
is gay
there's 12 of us in here
quiet let me start pointing fingers
jerry's gay
the other day i was like you
[ __ ] i didn't know you guys
trained together man yeah
tikki's our managers we've been training
at tiki's gym dude i've known tiki
forever so because you and i linked up
and then tiki text means hey it's tiki
man he's i'm working with brian i'll
take care of everything i'm like dude i
mean i haven't talked to him forever he
was on my uh ultimate fighter like 15
years ago dude wow me and tika were
close man that's where they had the best
prank yeah yeah yeah yeah to use i love
tj i've had a lot of managers and tiki's
by far the best he's well he's been
around for seven thousand years i mean
he's been around forever because he
worked with rampage forever right yeah
yeah i just saw rampage yesterday yeah
him in chicago he's uh his rampage and
shavers he's stupid he's actually
looking better really because he was
like he's like thank you
fight the fate of the fight he's like
290. no he's actually looking better
he's been training with mckee and those
guys up there in the little body shop
being motivated yeah he looks he looks
they announced fedor's fight yeah tim
johnson fight not a good fight for tim
no it's a great fight for tim
yeah i mean i i figured for fedor i
think tim i think tim knocks him out and
i give him 40. definitely yeah
but i figured fate or they'd like give
him like a josh barnett like another
legend
nah i don't know
he he wanted matt mitchell and then matt
had lost five in a row because he wanted
that fan they cut up yeah because matt
had lost five or six i thought they were
like would jack give him josh barnett
let john you know joshua yeah the issue
with joshua is you know if he's gonna
make it to the fight
you know he has problems with the
commissions
you know i know you're in russia we're
in russia i get it
i watched so four guys beat up one guy
in russia but as a promotion though you
saw that [ __ ] too i saw it
the
literally i watched three guys beat the
shot on one guy and it was a sanctioned
fight it was fantastic three versus one
dude it was nuts
but i think it'd be like one big guy
like the mountain from game of thrones
so yeah first three small guys is three
small guys versus one small guy the
first guy dives in just takes it down
and then the two guys just stomp them
out yeah i was like this is fantastic
they're building middle and i want to
donate to their building
dude
we watched that hunt down below did they
beat that it was actually it was
actually in poland but there's a ton of
like russian like team fights oh dude
russia they do the game of thrones ship
where they have gear and swords mma
fight you've seen that i can't get
enough of it
and the goal is to kill somebody yeah
and you tell me josh barnett can't get
sanctioned in russia i think it's a
promotion though you want to stay away
from things that might attract more
garbage for you
but josh barnett's a legend yeah but i
think he's been i think he got us
suspended again i think that's kind of
what the issue is though i think there
was some sort of suspension all right
something josh going on what about those
jose dos santos what about
uh i'll just have a fight and haven't
fought in bellator so why have those
guys fight there that's the biggest
thing so why have them fighting you guys
you guys did kimbo verse
this is before you got there but yeah it
was before no i actually just signed
with them oh really you worked that
fight yeah i actually interviewed that
was my very first interview before you
interviewed dada when he died
[ __ ] kimbo oh he was the very first
like you know it's like but you
died donald's like yeah he did that yeah
i didn't die
he died dude he straight up died inside
the gun and then they resuscitated him
and then he came back to life yeah
because i guess he kept so much weight
before that fight because he was like
290 out of shape 265. and they were so
out of
how about uh your boy uh well your old
friend chad men has uh signed with bare
knuckles yeah i was surprised
i mean i think it's good for bare
knuckle like there's something there do
you have a better knuckled old friend
you watch it all right uh i don't
know you know what i'm saying [ __ ] let's
say [ __ ] like you've seen
men he's got a great contract man yeah
they do pay and i think they pay like
there's something yeah they pay well
there's something to bear knuckle i
think if they keep getting guys like
chad mendes stuff like that they could
be onto something yeah the thing is
looking but good but all the but all the
people they've signed up his hand looks
sick yeah he looks good right i see i
see a little video like yeah
or the bag i thought for sure he's
coming back to ufc they must not no when
i saw reti like out of retirement i
thought it was ufc and that's him but
she could he could come back and compete
yeah he could but it's like dude they're
offering him some good money yeah you
know yeah but you're fighting bear
knuckle you know but all of the people
that bear knuckles signed they're kind
of like on their way out that him he
could still be relevant in the way
classically if hatred rachel isn't you
know i'm saying like those are two like
they're good they're good but then they
were they weren't top level in the ufc
so they they went on you know they were
the chad was talking look at this yeah
that's what i'm saying yeah chad could
have sticked around he could have
started boxing
good bro like dude all the elk that he's
been killing like thank god go straight
through thank god he's retiring
giant traps there's jack i do so i've
i've worked out with that guy
trained with him for what like
four or five years and by far still to
this day the most athletic person i've
ever worked through really by far chad
chapman is for sure should have been a
ufc championship wow if you would have
had some cardio yeah
i'm sorry i'm thinking of chad connor
like eight days yeah
jose aldo chad mendes
earth right now like what's this ufc
thing about show them chad mendez versus
jose aldo too they had like that last
where the bell rang and like yeah like
they even had like that couple
iconic little moments and like oh what
the [ __ ] yeah yeah i'm getting some time
was over or not yeah
yes i
strength too like we'd start in like
situations
and he'd always [ __ ] win the
situation we'd even start like full log
like worst case position like full lock
triangle all you just posture out of it
every time he's just a beast he's just
too strong it's insane the guy's uh he's
a he's a he's an animal that's a good
guy did he start he started a company
do you start a company with clay guida
they don't like fishing slash like
hunting companies he does fins and
feathers it's a guide service and they
also do uh fishing as well too they take
you on like hunting tours yes so i would
do he has like celebrity guided tours so
i'm going i was supposed to i've been on
hunts for him he's on the term celebrity
but yeah i was supposed to go i was
supposed to go on a tuna trip three days
after my fight but i got knee surgery so
i couldn't go
um but something like that went up on a
mule deer hunt so he like sends out like
five different guys and i hunt with
these guys i go and stay with them i
can't how long is it
it's like four or five days i'm out yeah
i'm thinking like a day or two i mean
you i mean five days of like camping
live in the woods but dude i mean some
of these places are like like nice ass
like
it's not the same when you can't sleep
in your porsche no no this is this this
kind of guy if i can't fly to four
seasons i'm out yeah
this kind of camp is like a four
thousand square foot cabin
four thousand square foot gathering yeah
you're not liking it oh it's nice and
some of it's like very very and so you
just walk out yeah
they'll take you in a truck that's more
at brandon's valley yeah
he's in texas or something we just [ __ ]
all over so i have a mule deer hunting
in uh utah he does oregon montana i'm
sure oh yeah
so definitely he finds these hunts
because of his name and what he's doing
and then he resells them to the public
to give them a deal to go and hunt with
himself or my like me or paige van
zanstein hunts with him or like other
does she know how to hunt
i have no idea tell chad i'm [ __ ] in
dude i'll do that yeah i mean i don't
know how to shoot a gun but [ __ ] you you
learn yeah i'll talk about your air off
yeah
i'll scare all the animals
he's like you can do the little horn
cook a mean [ __ ] steak
oh yeah that's a good idea that's what
chad's been doing yeah he's doing the
ass fins and feathers man he's been
doing a really good job with it so he uh
i pretty much started fighting to feed
his hobby and his hobby was hunting and
now that he was doing good in hunt um
fighting when he retired he's like
turned hunting into a job so he's doing
what he does he's doing it
murdering animals left and right
yeah yeah but dude like to be honest
like it's the most ethical way to eat
for sure if you're gonna eat like when
you go out and buy something at the
store chick-fil-a
that animal yeah
trees like like so good camp so you
can't have it yeah that's what you're
doing
before but then somebody broke
if more people would hunt there'd be
less like cruel teacher overall like
cattle and uh
[Laughter]
you don't you've never hunted before no
because that is i mean i grew up in
[ __ ] northern california you know
like like
bro yeah well so you know but you just
drove up in a different part
[Laughter]
no but it's something that i like after
like listening to people talk about it
on jerry i'm like that sounds [ __ ]
awesome i'm glad i do i just want to be
like a trek for like three [ __ ] days
yeah so i like doing like the [ __ ]
two week back country by myself [ __ ]
20 mile hike back in the like i like
doing [ __ ] where i disappear my phone
don't work
no one can get a hold of me
like straight up like savage
like me and my brother my dad we go to
idaho
we hike back
take like a week's worth of food with us
if we don't get nothing with a week
we're talking like beef drinking [ __ ]
like canned food we actually do we'll
take like we'll take fillet like so
the first stuff we take out there is
like all the frozen [ __ ] like the nice
fillets and the hamburger you make
spaghetti with and show off the campfire
yeah but eventually you eat through that
and then you guys are eating dehydrated
meals yeah you know
they taste good but they're dog [ __ ] my
friends gave me [ __ ] because we went
camping and i brought a rotisserie
chicken that was fully cooked no hell
yeah yeah
everyone wanted it you know yeah
i'm sure eventually you guys ran out of
food then you know we do berries and
bugs and [ __ ] we gotta we then we go
back into town yeah i can hike back into
town for the most part we take enough
food but
i mean you're only gonna be in the
wilderness for so like we're out there
for a week i'd say after a week we
haven't killed nothing because if you
kill something you have to come into
town but if you haven't killed anything
yet after a week i'd say we'd come back
in but you have to like as they say you
have to address it like take like your
skin off and like if you kill so we kill
a elk
i mean you're bringing 800 pounds of
meat you're carrying some [ __ ] yeah but
but don't you have to
where it is rogan was saying that you
have to dress it fast because the bear's
a smell yeah for sure like montana
yeah idaho montana i'm in montana
september man so we won that round
when we uh
kill it you gotta quarter it out yeah
fully skin it cut it into force hang it
in the trees put pepper all over it
white pepper because the bees
the meat bees will come and destroy it
oh interesting yes you put pepper all
over it cage control and uh you gotta
hang it high up in the tree hopefully a
bear doesn't even though she kept very
comfortable kind of funny who who had uh
so i had two i teach him one in the
first and i had t-shirt lose in the
second so i think it's one one going on
in the third has anyone been paying
attention i just like having
keep glimpses yeah yeah uh but i'm
thinking i thought i had a 1-1 i have
one i think you have a fight coming up
soon
three weeks when three weeks oh damn
against uh jj
okay
that'd be fun
yeah chilling
who's j.j
eldridge ah okay okay okay
she's a little stud how do you feel
i feel good yeah a little tired just got
off the plane yeah where are you from
where you live arizona oh okay okay you
live here in la area yeah
phoenix are you in the huntington beach
area like costa mesa yeah
yeah because i think i'm at the gym too
yeah yeah because i used to go down and
train with when they were in the shitty
ass hole in the wall gym right there off
of uh ocean was it off ocean well i
don't know i never went to the church do
you still go to black house ever no
that's no thing
i'm old
how old are you
thirty-eight well they used to have
everything yeah i've been out of the
game
yeah they used to own the one called
ultimate
all the time razor rob would fly me down
because razer and i fought reference
razor rock yeah
he's still
yeah do you know his name and [ __ ] he's
good yeah he's good
yeah he's good no he was working for the
ufc gyms for a while he's like one of
their top yeah
i don't think he is i think he's done
with it right now during right now he
maybe brought him back on but or shane
he put him on i don't know as far as i
know he's still looking for him got it
got it because i talked to him about it
two months ago and said he wasn't there
forever
wc day yeah yeah i fought him in the wfa
i thought of one of his homies he was my
uh fighter coach
racer he was like the main guy holding
that because i was busy busing with my
coach so tikki
razor rob and oh yeah cause basement
dreamworld brady was a juicy coach but
they all show up like
half hour late so drunk yeah but people
don't get something coach yeah the
coaches are experiment right now like so
we've never been live we didn't practice
at 10 a.m really they'd be showing up
straight at like 10 a.m yeah like
it's still like glitter on them and
she's like man i never really liked
spearmint rhino i went to club paradise
when i was on there you could always
tell when the coach went to spirit rhino
because rampage and rashad like we're
sparring today yeah yeah just sit there
and like watch it
like we sparred yesterday dude like shut
up
bro when uriah was coaching the fighter
it was me and lance palmer they'd show
up like that's my pizza is a stud
he's so much fun i always have so much
we'd always show up with like an
eighteen pack right today's sparring
we'd be like drinking beer while
sparring dude just like watching spark
coach and talk [ __ ] yeah they didn't
show any of that stuff on the like they
don't know that [ __ ] none of the fun
stuff they don't show you know be like
getting hammered and coaching that you
thought it would be like you guys want
to sell something this is [ __ ] yeah
yeah they added all that nothing no
it's like professional athletes don't
drink
where where do they where do they
where's the house now for the kids is it
still a dope house uh
they change it their house was like
airbnb now off of
it was it's airbnb yeah yeah yeah it
literally was um well the house now is a
[ __ ] it was like two two three exits
from uh the strip the apex oh okay yeah
going towards summer there's like red
rockers and then like forgot it was a
dope house though it was cool we had a
pool like some room it wasn't
my in my opinion like when i saw the
show when you were on there and yeah
i was like dancing at a badass house
yeah the house i stayed at was
oh they put you in airbnb yeah they play
a station casino no they put oh i was in
the casino for a while until they almost
kicked us out because
but but did they put you in the gym but
we're at five in the morning
getting kicked out the [ __ ] the hotel
because
it's my little brother her
myself
and we start having a water fight in the
room
okay five in the morning five in the
morning okay all right check this out
that's our idea water fight like water
like grab a [ __ ] water bottle and
just throw it all over the place like a
liquid death of the yes yeah
and then next you know like
we start going live and [ __ ] and my
brother did
how's your brother now 16. dude last
time i saw him was when we're on the set
of tax collector [ __ ] remember that that
terrible movie we did
remember the worst movie in the world we
did i i mean i had fun i had fun too but
it was a bad movie yeah it would i
i'm not gonna say no
it was fun though it was it was dope it
was different it was my first time i
ever did something like that it was cool
seeing shyla buff
like you didn't like him
he was crazy we had that [ __ ] remember
like that's right he wanted to fight
like he was so in character he would
like fight fight yeah i've heard his
life like he tried fighting like the one
we slammed him on the table yes
do you remember when they had to cut
because he cut his hand because so he
was in a gang there's another guy in
another gang and we're at [ __ ] craft
service i'm eating like [ __ ] chicken
tenders and he attacks the guy from the
other gang dude no we're not excused
he's he's like the stuff i'm sitting
down and they start fighting and they're
like brian break it up [ __ ] like
my [ __ ] yeah they're playing touch [ __ ]
in the park
touched by the party then i was like
trying to kill them and then the next
day they try to keep them away from each
other and we're all pissed off because
he these two keep looking at each other
and we're like come on man like we just
want to get the scene yeah because
stop the shoots
oh for sure they have to like get his
angle this angle this angle
yeah you're like [ __ ] narcissus yeah
i love it
turns around and he starts talking [ __ ]
to the the guy and
[ __ ] it we snap and [ __ ] slam that
[ __ ] on the table and then he
tried to hit me like with the gun
and it went like this and it hit conejo
in the mouth remember and quinea was
like it was pissed yeah so i was holding
his hands and i was like choke him out
and connell is choking him like hey what
the [ __ ] is going on bro this is shia
labeouf right indiana oh
he's yeah but he's notoriously crazy
what like he's interested in his full
character yeah alex baldwin had some
issue with him doing a play on broadway
where he was like i didn't understand at
the point at that time i didn't you know
i don't know [ __ ] about he's a method
actor dude yeah yeah i don't understand
well he's got a real tattoo
yeah got his character's name tattooed
on his really stomach yeah i was like
you know this moves me at like 18 on
rotten tomatoes right
like and you have a tattoo yeah yeah
that's correct but your main takeaways
you're saying you got to get this angle
that and go and you have to realize like
how boring it's not shooting a film and
you have to keep the same energy the
whole time yeah it's like get ready for
this
day where you're going i was solid yeah
that was your first acting
yeah that's a real tattoo oh my god
that's him off keto he was on keto on
set there you go
right there
with the glasses yeah yeah that was when
he was on that's true that's when he was
on set that's
right
yeah yeah
that's when he was attacking and just
the one on the stomach the ones on the
left are really just just his stomach
just this one says creeper this
character's name yeah you should've got
all of it dude you're crazy
remember when he put that bag on his
head and was like i'm not a celebrity
anymore
he's a
oh those are real man like chin if you
google like mark harley shia labeouf
there might have been like a movie
player that i was in where i did
something similar that's what you did
it was crazy to me see how talented he
was remember spoiler alert movie's been
out for four years to suck my dick
remember when he uh when he had to die
in the movie and they have to keep
recreating the scene when he gets shot
negro was shooting him and i uh shooting
him and then he has to pretend he's dead
i i wasn't there that day he went there
that's the final scene dude seeing him
act like that i was like holy [ __ ] he is
a good actor
and to see him do it over and over and
they'd be like from the hungover games
premiere how many times some articles
got written about it
for
12 hours oh acting is terrible it was
awful you've been in a couple movies now
right um
no not only that one uh it was i did a
we were like a part of la originals okay
yeah that and then i just did one with
uh i take it easy no no no no no no no
they call me no i know it's like
[Applause]
it more like i'm a stupid [ __ ] like oh
no i feel you like i don't know anyone i
just know you by who you played like
when [ __ ] uh like rdj that mickey
ward guy
uh
he was a fan and they hit me like hey
rdj wants to talk to you what the [ __ ]
is like rafael dos like what the [ __ ] is
rdj yeah
yeah uh robert downey jr oh wow
so i'm just talking about iron man yes
that's nice yeah okay so i'm in the
garage working out and they said okay
he's gonna face him what the [ __ ] i like
ten percent battery angle also who faces
face i mean i was like oh [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] iron man i was like hey what's
up bro like oh hi all right he's giving
me advice for like a fight or something
no i just talk actors are so [ __ ]
gone he's like all right bro i've been
watching a lot of your video yeah no he
was he was cool bro he was just like hey
i want to get to know you and everything
oh weird and then uh
get to know you
he was like where are you from i'm 28
bro
like say make a wish
i thought it was cool like i felt so
special i felt special
because he was a fan yes that's dope and
then uh
so [ __ ] get to know you those little
we both we both spent the night in the
same jail station before so we kind of
bonded off that right
different reasons though right yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
this was for some uh
you know mine was my super
was really stupid uh those were back in
the days though dude he fully reinvented
himself he's crashing yeah but yeah it's
some tough days anyways uh another
special shout out
yeah i feel you that's my point uh yeah
great story though another special shout
out to sponsors tonight manscape the
official electric trimmer of the ufc if
you haven't tried the new lawnmower 4.0
it's like a spaceship it's shaped like a
dick it's got a 400 or 4000k led light
so you can navigate it in the dark and
if you're shaving nuts in the dark you
got bigger problems uh you can trim your
balls body and even
your ass uh have your balls feeling like
they have zero gravity help your little
planet stay fresh with the sun's heat
with the performance package no one's
touched that dude yeah get you some look
at him go dude
he's doing it he's really doing it mark
will shave your head if you want uh
all thick boys tonight get 20 off and
free shipping with the code cfc at
menscape.com uh that's 20 off and free
shipping the code cfc at menscape.com
we got the link in code in the bio
okay
there we go yeah i remember when i was
shooting that show uh tax collector and
i thought it was like gonna be my big
breakout debut i was gonna be the rock
and then they gave me a mask and i was
like oh i don't want to be in a mask and
i didn't know it worked like that and so
they gave me a gun that had a mask on
and i was like i'm not wearing this
[ __ ] mess so i took it off i was
firing the gun here cut like negro mask
on i was like yeah no doubt
put the mask on took it off
just cut negro where the [ __ ] mask i
was like nobody's gonna recognize me
dude got the [ __ ] mask
in the movie so unless you really know
who i am can barely see me in the movie
though yeah i get a mask on this one and
this
my character wouldn't do this because
yeah yeah i was wearing a [ __ ] mask
man
i dude i i got derek lewis man i got i
got to i woke up this morning i thought
dirk lewis he's a better odds now but i
definitely think gaines is going to win
man
win by submission if dude derek lewis
yeah no you can still place the bat on
draftkings
i bet all the time yeah yeah are you
everyone you bet on this one i did put
money on derek lewis now he's
even though the all week you've been
talking about how we got back
nuts for months i've done sill guns nuts
i just have this weird feeling derek
lewis gets done in his own hometown
he's so [ __ ] hard but the thing about
sarah gone it's like his his footwork's
so good and if you look at his fight
against rosenstroke he doesn't get
[ __ ] hit
but so to hear how much more
he's derek lewis has been training
just really makes me think how much he's
overthinking and did you hear derek
derrick lewis goes i'm just gonna i want
to be fight of the year and hopefully i
get a knockout i'm going at them because
that's the thing about cyril god it's
like he means you just sit back he just
picks you apart if you go no one's
really gone at him yeah so we'll see
yeah i don't know dude that's crazy
right
because you were talking to dc about the
pressure did you see that they had that
similar moment
yeah wait pressure fighting in his
hometown and everyone being there oh
it's the worst you know there's many
fighting hometowns like even when i do
when i'm on the comic tour if i go to
denver you know like so many people you
like you better yeah you're sleeping in
your bed i fought honda center and i
fought yeah forum yeah but isn't your
whole family and like aunts and uncles
sitting up for free tickets and [ __ ] oh
dude no no no majority
[Applause]
who's listening fighters get four
tickets maybe more if you're a main
event so it's still maybe six don't
[ __ ] happen
how much i get hooked though yeah
so
what i did was i created i had
so um so i created like a a card you
give out and i had an assistant that i
basically paid and she just had all my
ticket sales so i gave her i gave her 10
of whatever she sold so if you still
would beltor give you more than four no
no i'm talking about when i was with
strikeforce oh strike four stuff so
right so okay because i was in san jose
yeah yeah so san jose so we'd sell out
that's like your fight island yeah so
it's like my fight island so basically
what i did i handed out a card business
card it had her contact information was
for tickets only so her phone would blow
up boom ten percent so you know
but i was selling 200 000 tickets she
was making damn damn she's making good
that was a great side hustle yeah so it
was because bellator gives you 12
percent of whatever yeah
[Music]
yeah i was selling [ __ ] tickets on
the side of the freeway yeah when you
first started on the way to my fight
yeah yeah hey [ __ ] hold up go
[ __ ] i'm parked right on the 405 and 110
like yeah yeah yeah
like [ __ ] like dude
you're late what the [ __ ] do you
remember
you remember your fight before you got
the ufc when i was in the back with you
the
when you were warming up
you and and uh no they didn't fought too
on the same card remember he was the
main event you were like co i think no i
was the main event no dear usual right
no no that was respecting that was a
title fight that's right you were the
main man that was respecting the cage
that's right after was elephant yes
that's right you went yeah yep i was
nervous i was like hey bro uh
having fun in a while yeah
it's just you and me in the back yeah i
was like what the [ __ ] do i do yep
i said because like i didn't fight for a
while but it was two years before five
yeah he had a little bit of great in his
beard and it was off to the [ __ ] legs
like i couldn't believe when i come out
the beginning of the round for like the
first minute you're doing all right man
yeah i'm doing all right yeah
i mean i i've actually tried to look up
tate on instagram to thank him
personally who's this tate the corner
in the corner he [ __ ] saved me
because
i got cut in the second round and i
could not [ __ ] see yeah worse could
have all done but when i came out for
the first minute of every round i like
gold yeah i noticed that i'm like oh
they actually stopped the [ __ ]
but then you just rub the vaseline off
and [ __ ] happens you start bleeding your
eye again but it does give you something
like the reason why they didn't stop
that fight is because tate was able to
keep that [ __ ] under control you know
they were thought in the second round
we'd have to rematch a bunch of [ __ ]
i was like thank you awesome man yeah
jesus christ yeah uh if you are betting
dope as a human being too yeah yeah it's
a good joke dude yeah yeah how good are
those [ __ ] liquid deaths yeah another
one yeah
i'm drinking beers yeah right it looks
like a beer if you show up to the gym
and everyone's like oh he's drinking
beer before he benches that's cool
it's just water it's just water kids uh
if you are a betting man michael kiesa
is an underdog and i
hear you and i have money on him wow
i better i think
yeah i bet on him too
he's so big i saw him when he was
fighting 55 ran into him one time i was
like 55 [ __ ] do you make 55. i was like
good god
i'm standing next to him like speaking
of being are we still in the same way
he's the biggest 45 of all time right
not anymore you're enormous who else is
there who's bigger max is my height
holloway yeah yeah but but he doesn't
have that well no he gets pretty big man
max hit him up about 1805
yeah
[ __ ] yes i got up to 1910
let's not do that it's so funny hey
my first thing
my first in the ufc joe you said rogan's
turn all the time oh josh the probably
the biggest [ __ ] 55 pound i've ever
seen i look at the 55 pounders now god i
should be like a 35 pounder what the
[ __ ]
guys are enormous man well there's this
other guy too who uh
who is it um
is it b is he is he is six two bro
that's crazy he's standing here he's
standing here standing here his
brother's good his brother fights for
bellator
he did i think he's i don't think he's
gone yet allegedly he looks like a
hormone
yeah
he's bro his brother's good too you know
exactly what i'm talking about yes
he looks like the hormones
we have we have a thing with like a mask
yeah i love that gentleman whoa that's
just my [ __ ] so yeah zabeet i think
retired he's out
but yeah you're doing yaya rodriguez for
smacks why though why did he retire i
think he was just sick of this [ __ ]
i don't know because he's a stud yeah
he's
like he's hoping though right he's got
cove and i think he's just [ __ ] done
with it but mark henry before the beat
was like anything mark henry's coach who
i trained with trained me for my cro cop
fight he was like dude i'm telling you
you need to talk about this is a beat
kid yeah he's in our gym he [ __ ] up
everything yeah like really he's like
he's a freak yeah and sure enough he's
he's a beast from what i see his
brother's good he's dead
yeah yeah yeah his brother fights in
bellator just had his first fight bro
yeah younger brother yeah does he look
like him he's not as tall i think he
fights at 35. harry not a snow that was
harry i don't know why that matters yeah
it turns you on we get it i'm just
trying to yeah we got some landscapes
yeah yeah
it's a beat needs manscape
i'm very excited for this fight this
this is technically probably the best
find the card if there's gonna be a five
tonight it's gonna be this one unless
derrick lewis can get a knockout this
has five night written all over it and
if chiesa gets him down it's [ __ ]
gamer he's a monster yeah
bruce buffalo
he got into it coach paul oh really yeah
oh he's on he was coaching another team
because he had a teammate on there or
something right
coach paul i love you is it hearing him
talk about how he gave up [ __ ] talking
like i figured he was he was being
interviewed although i saw that too i
think it's a mission radio yeah yeah i
love those guys yeah he's like
you know he's like i just realized it
wasn't me
for a while he was like talking [ __ ] and
he was like i just thought it was the
thing to do
he lost the fight and his coach was like
dude quit talking [ __ ] just yeah it's
not your thing there's a thing where
they fought right or or
the
kevin kevin lee yeah
don't talk about my mom yeah i thought
it came across
i love that chiesa in uh gaijin
commercial have you seen that it's such
a good commercial
so so good is that what what is that
that's for i don't know like beer or
something wasn't it a medela commercial
it's mo no it's not going down all the
limes right so it's like it's got to be
some sort it's for tequila right or
something because they both they're both
what's that what's the commercial
it's really well done though yeah it's a
really good commercial i don't know
so it's not that great i never want to
be that guy be like yo jamie pull it up
but i just did it right there sorry it's
all good it's okay
no volume though we can't oh [ __ ] i wish
it was fun but that's how it looks dude
versus champions yeah it's tequila
it's it was it's [ __ ]
great man dude if i see you on one more
toyo tire commercial i'm gonna freak the
[ __ ] out
when you got the acting chops i'm sure
it's not it's not cheap to keep those
[ __ ] tires on the jeep that's true
well those aren't toyo's
he's lying right now like
those big monster trucks yeah they make
those oh wow wow that's what i got on my
truck too toyota's yeah well you what
you have a you look like a raptor raptor
that's just that's about it
is it tuned oh yeah yeah yeah i went
through your boy dude
oh you went through my guy yeah oh type
movement i sent you to him that's right
yeah greg's great yeah he's awesome dude
yeah yeah got me a sick ass deal bought
out of state he works with canelo
everybody good job aunt or your raptor
mm-hmm in utah uh i bought it for the
east because you know in utah right they
have their whole facility there so you
have a full on track you can go there
and test drive it it's like a full
experience for a whole weekend yeah but
you got to fly to [ __ ]
you go to utah and they have their their
headquarters there you just drive like
they they running through tracks they
have you jump the cars it's all free
just
you have a defender the the only thing
it does is
really that's probably smart but well a
good player
good player board sometimes i'm still
looking at one more what what
are you like travis barkley you like the
old school [ __ ] i have two i have two
classics
63 impala
yeah but they're gonna do nothing to go
up in value those are sick ass
investments bro
the only car you should buy should be a
classic car yeah i have a driver
yeah yeah i have 85 el camino and a 63
super sport and then the jeep so you
have three jeep
and then now we invested in real estate
or
registered yeah no real estate yeah it
was he's so worried about the takedown
yeah he's so worried about the takedown
he's the main thing that's why the main
thing is real estate smart yeah kiasa
nix that's
if i look at him like how the [ __ ] did
you ever make 55 like how big he is gosh
man
it's like anthony rumble oh [ __ ] no i
just tripped on the fence mainly manly
tripped on the fence yeah the right hook
had nothing to do with it
you don't look
game is so good it's good
here's my pick for draftkings dog good
pick here we go he's underdogs
he's got it i wouldn't say i don't know
yet you don't think so no not yet not
yet he's 55 yeah he's got a whole reason
he's got a real hard time with guys like
with guys like covington and guys like
video
can't take him down he can't take his
men down not with that wrestling's gonna
jab the [ __ ] out of him no yeah look
i'mma kiss a fan i just i don't i don't
think he's here right now
oh
yeah
look at this guy i love shisha too is he
this is not where he wants to be again
oh oh
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh no [ __ ] no no no no no go go go go
you don't have it
that's a black belt son oh oh oh oh no
no no never kevin kevin he caught him
kevin lee caught him this is [ __ ]
tough
oh [ __ ] your next champion huh no way
nope not anymore damn
yeah
yeah apparently yeah
right
if he's not they need to give it to him
damn well yeah that the road to the
title is going to be tough
wow minor step back [ __ ]
well i apologize for anyone i convinced
to bet on i would have been on that
fight i'd better out about yesterday you
guys heard it here first though do not
vote do not bet on derrick lewis
he's been popping derek
that one's a dude as a dog and his power
because if you're gonna make money on a
fight you gotta take the dog well
especially when you've been talking up
gain all yeah
and then you're like oh my god
i did not see him getting choked up
well dude vicente lu the winner of this
is i mean right there could you you look
at the queue at 170. what do you finish
he knocked out woodley remember they
were exchanging yeah he knocked out
woodley yeah
how do you feel about the like jake paul
you got covington burns
like
leon edwards those are the top three
stephen thompson when i see people
getting money
that's what that's why i see vicente
lucas
[Music]
and you
when you look at it
like
some things that they have said
it's almost raising awareness and some
other [ __ ] that people don't have no
idea about like jake paul's going hard
on the paint on fighter pay which i'm
like dude yeah keep going
keep going you guys can't talk about
that yeah let's not get this guy's in
trouble three of you can't yeah i can't
but i can't yeah you can't do it i talk
hella [ __ ]
uh but do they get the viewers that's
what i was like you can talk as much as
you want they're gonna get paid because
they're literally elaine they're they're
getting the viewers no but i'll say this
all that stops if jake gets starch by
woodley all this youtube crossover [ __ ]
yeah it's done it comes with a
screeching halt yeah i don't know dude i
like it i always say [ __ ] like that but
then they come up with some other [ __ ]
that gets you be like did you see what
the [ __ ] you did
right you're always like if this happens
like they're done and then they'll do
some way out of not like i'll say this
like [ __ ] from left no i'll say this
brian like there's like youtubers can
fight other youtubers i'm saying as far
as him cross-pollinating with ufc like
real fighters i think that's out the
window if he gets starched who knows he
might [ __ ] with another legit fighter
and then people he's gonna make his he's
gonna make his way up though so if he
beats woodley he'll go to the next level
dude
i bet he fights connor
i would imagine probably that's your
biggest money because do you think
connor kind of has how many fights left
after nate what is their form yeah what
are you gonna do as far as my thing was
if you're gonna fight if you're gonna
fight jake paul like you have to figure
out
what way it's gonna be at jake paul's
big he's big compared to connor connor
walks around let's say he walks around
82 84.
yeah jake paul walks around 205
190.
that's small yeah
logan's a bigger one yeah i know logan's
a bigger one but i'm saying like he's
still he's 1990 you still want anything
logan's connor's timing for jake paul
would [ __ ] him up so bad though oh yeah
you would think you would have you would
[ __ ] hope
but who knows it's like
but the other thing with jake it's like
the only thing we have to go off of is
he starts spending aspirin right yeah
it's not we don't have a lot of sample
size there you're right we don't have a
big sample size on it but the power that
he possessed to do that not a lot of
guys have that power in in small gloves
not a lot of guys have that power i
agree
the thing though you got if you are a
guy fighting jake his timing is what
yeah anyone who has a trained eye you
see his timer like [ __ ] that kid can
kind of fight him you fight he's got
some skill he's dedicated to a world
champion but he's gonna be canelo but
he's up like the woodley's and these
other guys coming after him like if you
don't train seriously he's gonna [ __ ]
yeah all this [ __ ] is fun man it's a
bunch of kimbo and dadas i love it this
is entertainment
exactly we're here to make money
i'm doing a fight campaign for it for
god's sake yeah
when you look at what are they called uh
those type of fights
circuses no no no like uh [ __ ] shows
these money grabs
celebrities sign me up i'm sorry i'm not
gonna run that option here right help
they're all exhibition fights yeah so
not the jake paul ones though jake pawns
are real fights right no the whoa all
the television fights i feel like or i
don't know oh
that's the way they go
again
with floyd was exhibition
jake's fights are a real fight
they're real fighters
logan against mayweather
was that with an exhibition
how do you guys see aldo pedro munoz
dude if you watch all those last few
like even against uh [ __ ] peter yanni
look good man yeah that's good yeah i
mean like because we think stuff because
we've been watched what but but dude
he's the same age as pedro yeah
he just has some miles on him he's been
[ __ ] fighting so damn well i think
pedro wins he has more power for sure
he's just durable
i think i think i think if he just
started together so i like i always go
with the one i know yes
yeah
it was like all you guys were like the
top notch and like we were like the ones
pedro wasn't really fighting that time
he's like just the cheapest barely from
brazil yeah i think he's i think he's
got better cardio guillotine remember
that yeah great chain great cardio i
think he wins the fight jose uses his
kids he wins i think he wins he hasn't
used it
he's going to walk his time a little bit
against uh peter but it wasn't enough to
like make a difference he was tired he
looked he got tired and peter took over
the fight
for so long when i heard like i heard he
got like in a motorcycle accident ever
since then yeah someone said that you
can't kick anymore because someone's
kicked his legs i think it's because he
has two thousand fights well i just yeah
he's just it's gonna catch up with him
and i'm kind of wondering like if he has
the same type of like aging that they do
in cuba where he's probably like 50
because he looks like he's almost 50.
he's like says he's 32.
he owns a cheeseburger joint in uh
brazil he owns a soccer team he owns a
soccer team he has a soccer team in
brazil
yeah he's like he's a majority owner of
a soccer team soccer team's like nine
dollars out there but yeah
i don't know here in brazil bro they're
pretty good
it's like nine dollars
yeah i'm gonna buy seven teams yeah
uh
[ __ ] bread
yeah but we we think of jose aldo being
so old but him and [ __ ] pedo are the
same age as pedro hasn't fought as long
oh is that the [ __ ]
[ __ ] uh cody garbrandt that's the
highlight or no
i think they're trying to mix in a movie
and this is this this is you and
volkanowski is it it's got to be what's
wrong dude have you seen that
volcanowski oh
what's up dog okay hey can we bring the
long hair back or not i'm trying to okay
i'm trying to dude you you got your
hair's too good not to make it long dude
when you shaved i was so disappointed
yeah yeah you did it for a long time i
remember i was with you like threw your
phone at the phone i broke my phone my
phone was broke because you cut your
hair my phone is cracked right now what
all right so what do you do you're like
you're growing it out yeah you're
growing it out but what you can do with
it during the fight though you're gonna
braid it oh yeah yeah some braids what
dude
i'm gonna get out of there short hair
seven
harsh
so hard
[ __ ] up dude with those eyes along here
what are we doing dude those [ __ ]
eyes along here
brendan's ruthless when it comes to the
race
with long hair dude because i got three
babies by the way
i got three babies by the hair
i i got two already yeah she's like
we're out of control she was yeah maybe
there's somebody put the tip in oh i got
three babies by the tip let's play a
game just to do it just
let me see if it fits yeah
i'm so curious how uh
how uh nick diaz is gonna look yeah i
think i hope he looks good i think he's
gonna look good he's one of my favorite
fighters i hope it looks like everyone
likes the deal but here but both of them
are our favorite fighters like the two
of them were [ __ ] just like
legends
they were going to match them up against
rapidly because that was not in the
conversation before if they announced it
but then you're like oh no it was always
in the conversation piece the problem
was though they just the ufc was kind of
outside of the conversation the fans
were thinking you know what i would have
done if i'm the ufc i do nick versus
jorge because right it's like i'm
getting revenge for my little brother
jorge needs a fight like dude that would
be so much but i think you used robbie
as a he's like one of those fights like
hey
you don't know what nick said my little
brother [ __ ] like i'm a big bro
but why isn't jorge fighting [ __ ]
covington
why is that fight not happening because
i'm trying to fight cover just trying to
fight for the title yeah
dude it's crazy though
that fight for sure happened all right
call them out yeah you're big enough
dude
yeah yeah look they didn't look the same
weight class at all
dude he used to be 270 pounds do you
know that played bro
yeah he used to be like 200 he used to
be so thick have you ever seen him when
he was like super pokemon i'm sure he
was on a super bowl
right he's on the [ __ ] yeah
no way
bring up how thick he used to be i'm
telling he was like 240 i know but that
little bastard's not [ __ ] getting his
legs were like [ __ ] i know a creatine
user when i see one
[Laughter]
so don't go saying he's all natty he's
taking that there he's on that creek
protons
you want to see mark sweat mentions
legit
look at him though though
jacked
that's what two
he was 240
go where his face is all fat like mine
right there
damn tj funny comments somebody left on
my page was uh he's like you should you
should uh fight tj for the bantamweight
title i'm like look i can cut down on
short notice it's just getting past
usada with all the craziness
you saw as a [ __ ] bro yeah you ain't
gonna do it
danny's thick boy he said i know you've
been pretty
what's that
oh damn
she's pretty though i'm not sure if
that's his wife you have kiddos too yeah
yeah that had that was a chicken she's
flats too she's wearing firewood heels
she's like you can't just take them off
you don't want to slip those off for the
picture with my belt or
shaking i'll leave them on
like like get slightly behind me work
some angles did you have him beaten uh
holloway
uh which one did you even watch him or
not they didn't even
second one yeah yeah
i had holloway win the lost the first
one won the second one yup okay cool
first one he lost his leg kicks correct
yeah
holloway versus uh [ __ ] uh
with the mexican kid's name yeah
oh nice yeah that's going to happen
what's happening or his chill calls him
no something happened right yeah what's
up
something might have happened he's out
again i think it was out hollow he got
injured hallway or oh you might be right
hallway backed up bro got injured i
think yeah
i thought i loved holloway man because i
remember uh
watching something like on ig yeah he
might be right
no so far nothing
it's in the work for the main event four
days yeah four days ago
four days ago that's a great fight yeah
oh it's still straight i think holloway
beats the [ __ ] out of a [ __ ] thing
the first fight was it was called off
because of an injury or something okay
that's first of all yeah you're just not
active enough yeah you're right because
it was supposed to happen
though
for sure
no but yeah so athletic dude nuts
yeah i wish i could steal some
athleticism if i could take your brain
putting out here
yeah dude we're going on we're going
to stop about
taking you're unstoppable mm-hmm i want
to stream your brain like the movie get
yeah cause i just went because i'm mean
as [ __ ] yeah you're an [ __ ] for sure
hundred percent you gotta be 100
yeah i've heard stories
monster tiki was afraid to put me in
here together actually for a bit
yeah
yeah how crazy to see pedro at the level
he's at now because when we started yeah
black house he was just a guillotine
like jiu jitsu coach me and him were i
was 18 and he was
super young i was 18 and he was 19 20.
how do you know uh 30. nice
and we're [ __ ]
both you guys are [ __ ] crushing it
yeah we went to respect to the cage
together
we went to lfa together went to ufc
together nuts
you guys don't still train together do
you no he's in he where's he at brazil
yeah he's in florida yeah
he's in florida we train we never really
even train together just roll we trained
when we were 18 for a bit yeah and then
me and him like to just rock and sock
them robots yeah
and then uh who's this
me and pedro
[ __ ] what 12 years ago now he said he
seemed like a nice guy yeah i talked to
frankie edgar and i was like he's like a
really good guy frankie and i were
really good friends and frankie was
telling me he's like hey yeah because
i was i was 18. he was fresh from brazil
so we both had some approve i wanted to
prove that i belong at black house
he you know like he want to make a
statement like we had some dogs at
blackheads yeah we would just rock and
suck
it was just sparring i learned no
technique yeah you're just gonna get in
there and you just [ __ ] spark it was
nuts
that's crazy yeah yeah anderson silva
machida you guys were aka
was there you were there jake maybe jake
ellenberg i think was jake would be in
there yeah that's right uh that [ __ ] was
called sinister it wasn't even called
blackout did you try that pat cummings
yeah yep
monsters great clip of islam aka chef
like manhandling that ca state champ or
the national like high school
champions kid wrestle for dc and uh
you're right
he's like this is [ __ ] like flip
something
yeah
is it ak yeah was it aka the california
champ kid like talking
no no they were just he was a young kid
came in he was he was a senior that year
he was getting ready he ended up winning
state that year he's a stud yeah he came
in and mocked chelsea
having the real russian tie just [ __ ]
just
oh dude i told you hit the russian whip
down you can pull it up you can play
chase uh saldana say i think his name is
but it's on youtube as well he just he
rush and whips him down they make him
inside wrist tie and just [ __ ] whips
him down the ground back on the mat and
he's like oh [ __ ] and like like you know
get that [ __ ] i want that [ __ ]
that kid's fourteen though and that
could be no no national champion no
state champs he plays the michigan state
right now oh he's that much like a
full-ride scholarship [ __ ] yes
look right there used it boom [ __ ] you
use it after they go did you they
announced mike chevro's uh
i told you ah that's the fight bro it it
kind of is but it's come on he's going
to walk through him man but but
we need him to get more yeah he's going
to walk through him though but that's
what we want i know because if he
struggles at that then we know he's not
there
he has trouble one take down mocks the
floor i think one or two
a [ __ ] night yeah he's just too big
for him man so all my friends were like
why aren't they doing like why isn't his
own facing why isn't shawn o'malley and
it's like that's not that's not the same
the business of it well i mean like i'm
just using these two guys yeah
people who will be like why aren't they
facing like it's good they're building
top five no yeah but if you if you pull
up the rankings though there's no really
for him to fight because everyone's
already matched yeah we went through
this last time we had the guys in the
top top
the last fight
no it airs on uh on food truck diary
with you and big oh that's right yeah
you got into it was that aaron throws
that dropping thursday yeah yeah we
broke into a lot with about our show on
that which was nice we talked about a
lot and big john just i had all these
ideas on judging and stuff and big john
just shut me down
you forget
bro welcome to my world and try having a
conversation with that guy on our show
and like no no it should be like this
he's like no no let me tell you why he
just breaks like josh step-by-step i was
like big john yeah hear me out here
standings are coming over they're boring
there's grapple knees to down opponents
yeah make it happen
dude he shut me down so far no he's like
his own business
oh then he breaks like how to get those
laws passed
yeah like all right dude you're no [ __ ]
yeah
i love your argument about islam the
other day that you have with big john oh
yeah yeah he's [ __ ] oh
like the first 10 fights yeah so like a
little bit with big john on that but i
also think i think
you know i think islam is going to be
champ like yeah but you have to you have
to i the reason why i'm saying with
islam is that you have to look it with
khabib right
his style is just go forward islam will
stand and make the fight a fight
he's just striking yes and he'll but he
will just take people just dominate the
position from top to bottom he's the
most dominant champion that's ever
walked the face of them by far by far
there hasn't been more one that's been
more dominant agree okay so when you
talk about islam right he will make the
fight a fight but he stylistically for
most people in fact he's a yeah he
hasn't had more of an entertainment
factor than he has possesses because his
striking is better because his
striking's better but his submissions
took out that even a chance of you
knocking him out like he was just well
not only that but what made could be
popular wasn't so much that he was such
a dominant wrestler it was his ground up
and the way he would talk [ __ ] to people
because the way like even with mike
he was telling barboza the same [ __ ]
he's like yo it's my destiny just tap
give up you're not going to get away
from me i'm going to [ __ ] smash you i
have to fight
yes i have to fight for the title it's
my destiny he did the same thing michael
johnson did the same thing to barbara
doesn't see connor double down on the
comments no jesus yeah oh dude i i
wouldn't i thought about it right now
but i just shut the [ __ ] up because i
don't know i should have brought it up
no it's like and i'm dude i love
congratulations but it's like oh bro
what are you doing hey i'm just letting
you know the ship sailed man i can't i
can't even fall in line with that i
can't i can't fight oh my god
i don't i don't i don't i think it's
like desperate now it's like oh no it's
not even fun dude yeah there was a
moment that press conference where
dustin's like you used to be way better
at this
that was yes the best
well i thought the best line was what
was it conor fast actually connor sleep
mcgregor you're fast mcgregor's sleeping
it's also tough because could be beat
the [ __ ] out of him you know what i'm
saying like if it was like a really
really close fight i'm like alright
well let's get let's get back into like
when we were trouble with brenda you and
i had this conversation before when we
said oh when they fight could be stand
up it's going to be too bad this and
that remember i'm like conor dick right
yeah but these were the heydays of
congress and i was like you can't hold
that against me i said i did say oh no
i'm gonna hold it against you because
now time has passed i'm gonna be doing
some [ __ ] like that yeah but now that
brian's here remember i said the worst
matchup for khabib is brian
remember that
sorry bro like i disagree and then
[ __ ] could be gonna beat me and then
you'd be like i [ __ ] you could be
nothing
no but what do you think about it
because
this is the only reason why i say this
and i and
as a martial artist martial artist i
would love that fight for myself yeah of
course because i know it would no you
want to test yourself but not not even
detest yourself
bro
this is the reason why he's been
wrestling his entire life and he's been
on top of people his entire life yeah
my entire life i've had the gracies on
top and beating the [ __ ] out of me
big and then
for the grappling aspect that's it
put it this way even if it's like i
wouldn't like all right let's say [ __ ]
you brian he'll never fight like i would
just love to grapple with the guy no and
it's more of like a
it doesn't come from a place of of oh i
want to fight him or beat him nothing
it comes from a place like yo
i want to see what i have yeah of course
and because this guy plays just like we
we dance the same rhythm in different
ways
we [ __ ] he's a top guy i'm a bottom
guy
and
i get i get i get i've been shooting
submissions from my back hey
[Applause]
but people forget people forget look
even though even though he even though
he did even though he could be such a
dominant wrestler his jiu jitsu from the
bottom as well as his all of his other
submissions they're khabibs he all of
his submissions are they're very good no
i'm not saying they're not he's not
brian but what i'm saying what i'm
saying though is he's just as good off
the bottom as he's on top
but no one could put no one but people
have and that's the thing like how do
you know
i've trained with him for seven years
captain aka one of them but you know i
cornered him for four or four or five of
his fights when he starts calling him so
i guess i've trained with him for years
he's not he's brown or taken up from the
bottom
no not for the no but he's not also not
someone that stays there he doesn't hit
submission from the bottom what he does
he sweeps you to get on top and that's
how he gets your suggestions he is not
in terms of submissions from the bottom
that's not his game but let's not let's
not be mistaken and that's what i'm
saying jiu jitsu is not the same
it's been proven it's not the same okay
and i'm not trying to just i'm not
trying to discredit jujitsu but the samo
fighters they've been doing jiu jitsu
for
decades for the generations of this okay
sure has been around but just to just
one aspect of fighting [ __ ] is a
mixture of what mma was before yeah so
we're just saying khabib on top brian on
the bottom yes brian also doesn't move
like traditions i i can understand
i don't have
like and and when i say like that like i
said earlier right now you might as well
i didn't even i didn't i didn't even i
didn't even know you [ __ ] were you
know yeah i get it i don't know [ __ ]
about this old people i get it no no no
no no no
i didn't know you're training with them
bro i don't know anything about one and
what gyms are yeah yeah i gotcha i don't
watch fights like pedro's dude
is a good like my ocean is just like
what if there's a guy that i would love
to fight
bucket lift like he [ __ ] me up or not
yeah
it would be him
of course i
when i watch his interviews i [ __ ] with
what he said yeah everyone
is legit when he speaks
people listen i [ __ ] like what he
says i love what he's about i love the
way he conducts himself i love the [ __ ]
that he says he's a true pro he's a true
pro and he's he's in my opinion like
i like to i would want to think yeah
like him because he would be he some
situations would happen and the way he
had words about it
no no the way he is i'm talking about
and i go damn bro like he said what i
thought but he he said it better yeah
yeah he's not yeah he's great i know he
like his heart is from a heart it's from
he's a good he's a really good person
and a good person he does a lot of good
stuff for his communities yeah he's
doing a lot of great stuff for like dude
all the guys that he's trained with
these come up and even when i saw like
sure that they're connor taking care of
us when i saw even when i saw the
condition and i saw like
uh
what his father said yeah i don't know
if you saw the interview yeah yeah yeah
yeah he goes i'll have him over at my
house that's when i said you know what
that's where like yeah because
that's why every time he says something
they'll ask him about stuff and he goes
he'll explain his thoughts and he goes
that's just my opinion yeah that's from
my opinion yeah i think that's why the
connor stuff's so cringy it's like god
dude you're [ __ ] with a good guy yeah
yeah yeah and he beat you dude yeah
that's the other one yeah i'm just i'm a
fan of the guy yeah who's not it's hard
not to be though it's hard not to be and
then like when we were both in ufc i was
like uh my fight i'm so like
and then like after that like the more i
watch i go dude like i [ __ ] with this
he's a good dude like he's a good dude
but if you guys do if you guys do do a
submission thing
you and i bet on it huh all right i'm
down thousand bucks
how much you said you walk around 180
no no that was way back like that's when
i was a fat piece of [ __ ] yeah what's up
how much you walk around now at 160.
that's the thing he walks around 190.
he's out of shape
he is never out of shape bro
he's sparring with these guys right now
we're getting ready for fights he's
never out of shape that [ __ ] man he's
watching everybody's walking
he's running
around all the great ones they like he's
just saying that he's the same thing oh
he doesn't wake up he trains
in the trouble he does the joke right
like in terms of like he's training all
the time
he's probably training twice a day
over jon jones going backwards because
he's so dominant and john like
no i don't i i feel like the dominant
group is fighting yeah you can see two
different things i agree with him on the
different conversations one is the most
dominant champion ever and the other one
is the most talented and then the longer
longer that's the thing long right
they're just two different people yeah
i'm usually on the side of john you win
in march
technical like
like everybody's good at everything yeah
so the the talent level's so much higher
could be dominated at a better the most
dominant division and
really never lost a round maybe
quinte give him maybe one no no he
jumped out there
he lost apparently he lost one round to
um to conor supposedly but then someone
said he also lost a round to um glycemic
they said that
you need him for one round the first
round the who said that
the judges
the same yeah he was like i'm knocking
break your arm yeah i'm not gonna hurt
you because i know you're gonna tap so
i'm just gonna put you to sleep i don't
win the first round huh 10-9 i don't
think so i i just saw a tweet i thought
mate i thought uh munoz won the first
round now remember when khabib said
beginning of year you tap like chicken
oh that was a good good good good this
is crazy oh man
i think uh aldo looks better the second
round though although it will stay more
disciplined
and then but he's too patient yeah but
pedro will will uh go more into that
like [ __ ] it let's bang like watch right
here damn he's so good pedro will like
see the technical yeah and then pedro
will probably blitz him in if he gets
frustrated with the technical pick man
if aldo kicks don't change the game he's
too tired i'll go in that third round
but he gets tired yeah he gets tired
right there
all the wins we could be seeing now
although you know this time next year
it's gonna be dope just putting it out
there oh [ __ ] this is 35 bro yes i
forgot
he was so dominant he was so dominated
45 that he was someone going to 55. and
then now here he is at 35. he looks like
he's slowing down right now he will do
what he always is he always i wish he
could five-round fight you knew it's
kind of like coming right this can't be
a boxing match he he always like wins
the beginning of the rounds he has a
beautiful with with the power of his leg
kicks and with the calf kicks changing
the game i'm surprised he's not just
going to the well on him
he's so quick and so good right here i
heard him take that kick
down the right hand god [ __ ] jose's fast
man
oh i gotta throw some punches to set
that one up mm-hmm
it's crazy to think that he looks like
he's about 50. like he's [ __ ] he's
younger than me what is he 32 34 34.
my wife's like i can't believe all those
younger knows already dude this year i
turned 30. 30 30. [ __ ] you're in the
prime man
you are
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
i was sad that it goes fast man it was
way too fast
it's the best part i remember being 22
that 27 to 32 years 28 years old being a
champion yeah [ __ ] yeah
i'm 35 old as [ __ ]
at least you're a champion [ __ ]
i gotta get there still getting it bro
there's a leg kick there was one
go to the calf though keep going on the
[ __ ] leg twice yeah he's just some
good body shots that body shot's nasty
yeah there's some dogs jose's a dog even
if he wins this it's like what do you do
yeah i feel like right now
i think right now in the sport 135 is
the stat most division in all of the
shows
[Music]
or did is pitbull retire
no uh the i think what what pippa wants
him to do is pimple wants him to fight
his brother patricki first to fight
before he fights him because he's the
champion 55 which makes sense go ahead
and try and you know fight my brother if
you pass my brother fifty-five
fifty-five
yeah
i get it you gotta you gotta have he has
never fought at 55. yeah i know i know
he's a champ of 45 but he's only one
little fight there's other fights for
him also in one fourth [ __ ] him and
adam works would be a [ __ ] great
fight adam
stud
good stand-up fighter just dog all the
way around
there you go stay
bro what's your take on aj
you know what he don't watch fights aj
mckee i just saw the highlight yeah uh
he's good he's cool every time i've seen
him he's being cool yeah he's i don't
watch his confidence
athletic yeah he's from long beach yeah
i see little things where like i guess
like i didn't think so either he was
talking and stuff but
i i knew the speed would be a factor
when he bought patrice when he fought
pit bull but i mean
it was a normal cross kick though yeah
but it was the height man is the speed
the speed is going to set it up though
every time you do the jab he actually
tried to parry the jab and that's what
happened he threw the straight the young
lion
head kick came up right after yeah yeah
he's a young lion i feel like patricia
was almost like where the the outdoor
situation is right yeah
dude no
they i've rolled with them
korean zombies
so santa like when they when they come
down was they to fight with them
then after that they came right back
for one of their other fights and then
they came over my gym and trained it
with me for a little bit for the week of
their fight they're good people they're
[ __ ] really good people
they're family i love the kids are so
great you see the kids running around
all fight week it's [ __ ] it's nice to
be here you see the kids running around
so fun you see the wives all stressed
out
you know but
but no great i just feel like he's he's
been doing it for so long he's been the
champ he's got the most wins the most
knockouts the most everything in
bellator it's like dude you've been
doing for so long you know you got a kid
who's 16-0 now but like
he's young yeah just coming up yeah yeah
young speed athletic everything's
approved everything everything you know
and not to mention his dad was a [ __ ]
that was a bad badass [ __ ] that
was really good antonio
[ __ ] he just fought out the longer he's
still mad at him his dad followed the
same card as him yeah he wanted to be
the first father-son to fight on the
same card yeah you know i think i love
what they got going on yeah it's crazy
bro i met her and i was like you trying
to poison my eyes or something like you
were who you worked for
oh [ __ ]
how'd you guys meet oh [ __ ] oh no okay
another time yeah
[Laughter]
oh
tinder huh i feel like we're on a blind
date tell us how you guys met tell me
how you met a blind date
this shit's great yeah she shot her shot
shoot her shoes
did he have long hair or bald hair
long hair long hair oh okay okay
okay
she catfished your ass
that's funny i look like all them
that's [ __ ] great
world thinks i shot my shot
i wish he would just kick man if alder
if aldo would kick and set up his his
hands a lot more
i guess the the buzz around is that he
something's going on with like yeah
he wouldn't kick it yeah he wouldn't
kick yeah something with his like his
foot or his shin he's got something
going on yeah
that's what happened with me like i
fought gilbert the first time right and
then in between me fighting him the
second time i broke my ankle and i have
a plate in my in my ankle with nine
screws so every time i would kick if i
kicked with just like my the front of my
foot or if i hit your elbow it would
[ __ ] almost drop me damn like
anything like if you once you hit the
plate the plate hurts me more than it
hurts
i would think that it was
yeah it [ __ ] hurts you way more than
it hurts
way more not even a little bit the also
too what you have to remember is it
takes away your flexibility like your
bones they'll sometimes still bend a
little bit when the plates in now that
plate is like a fulcrum so now the bone
breaks over it so every time i kick with
it after i healed it up and had the
plate in is every time i came with it
like another couple months after i would
break the the bone
jose plate i told my connor breaking his
leg no mine when i broke mine no no we
were talking about the fact
and when i fought gil the first time
that was like the well i went to the
well on the body kicks after for the
second fight i couldn't kick because i
broke my ankle in training so i have
nine screws and a plate every time i
kick i'd break the bone above the plate
oh good oh there's those kicks
and how'd you break it in training
pedro
i was training with this kid named billy
evangelista and uh he came in he was the
guy that came in the last round
he was brian over here he gave me the
last round some punches off there so
oh we got a scramble
and i went to st i went to stand up and
he went to jump on my back
and he didn't make it all the way and so
he pulled me back or he fell on my ankle
coming backwards so his whole body fell
on the back of my ankles and you could
just probably just slow motion it was
like being rolled up on like an
offensive lineman just [ __ ] got
rolled up on it was horrible man you've
been paying attention is it uh
so i've been walking
i missed i missed the first minute and a
half did he did did pedro get dropped
right now no he's not making it yeah
oh grass right hand
i think it's 1-1 right now right i think
i think aldo's winning right now
there it is
i'm telling you man his leg kicks will
make a difference in the game yeah the
whistle pig's good
buffalo trace buffalo
yeah i love buffalo trace but if you're
if the whistle pig especially the 18
yeah it's good
[Music]
have
we go from having somebody's back to
being submitted like within a minute yes
that's gonna be a pretty rare welcome to
me yeah right yeah cheese he chased that
arm bar though
if you know you got 10 seconds left like
go for it captured it oh it hurt him
good good oh good combo god he's [ __ ]
getting fired with those kicks man if
you put the kicks in it changes the
whole game that's it he's gonna run he
won yeah he won this fight
yeah he should have you put the kicks in
it changes his if you if he throws his
kick and then he throws off the hands
with the hands right after he's [ __ ]
money bro you've had so good on the
prelims uh on espn you've had uh all
decisions one submission jessica penney
one via decision i'm sorry just uh
submission and then this main card
you've had all decisions one submission
so hopefully this is finding out yeah
hopefully this main event
oh three jobs five rounds of gone
running dude that would be a
nightmare do you if he ufc is gonna be
so sad if he wins
yeah that lay kick man i think he's
going to though
gods are i know he's just like gone
i i think derrick lewis
is an athlete bro i know he's a straight
up athlete like he's going to be smart
he's going to come out and be like look
the only way this guy beats me is if he
hits me with his [ __ ] right hand
you're just going to avoid it i know why
would you not if god if god ends up on
bottom at all
done i don't see how that's going to
done i mean
didn't have a [ __ ] prayer landing on
him
i mean i like derek lewis he's [ __ ]
yeah i'm sure dopey wins but i think
with derek lewistow is he explodes
whereas rosenstruck doesn't do that he
just stands there kind of like stalks
after you and just kind of helps you
come close i love his awesome moment
yeah who is against volkov
oh yeah yeah he's like oh that's not
possum no that's not possible he was
really [ __ ] hurt really
he's he's a dog though
derek lewis hey didn't they make that uh
ref shave his beard no no he didn't come
in no he cut it no no
ufc makes them tuck it in yeah did
something happen did it tickle somebody
else you just don't like it
they don't want him they don't want him
to um look like there you go no they
don't want him to build a character no
they don't want people i don't recognize
him as a character interesting because
like big john's not so big with his name
big john mccarthy yeah not too famous
they don't want that they want the
fighters they they want the ufc indeed
to get all the yeah
you know that makes sense
i mean it does when you're talking about
like where you're politicians
pedro no no so funny though those
considerations like hey hey buddy
yeah we want you to be dope as [ __ ] he
let me [ __ ] fight
the fight before when i seen you yeah
with one shoulder just because he knew
like i was still in it yeah he's a great
guy he knew my shoulder was out i fought
fourth and fifth with one shoulder yep
but with one arm and he he was like now
i seen something in your kid yeah he's
stuck and now he's like look where you
are now
where i met you there's a place to eat
around here
we got pizza back there yeah we have
something starving from marijuana okay
just don't eat in the mic though you
know
yeah you got this yeah
yeah you won
if i saw the guy on the street i
wouldn't think he speaks
portuguese it's not bad bro yeah it's
like uh you have someone run your diet
yeah
i have this guy named uh andy ah he's
good
yeah who you used to tj or no no
no no i just know him i went to school
there
cal state fullerton yeah
so he's got a good bro
no i just uh
he's a big [ __ ] dude though man i
have problems eating healthy yeah
yeah
i yeah i have bad problems like i yeah
you like food okay yeah dude mexican
food every food
i don't give a [ __ ] what it is a
jack-in-the-box chick-fil-a like
like uh
if you look at me and you think like oh
that guy's a professional athlete or a
fighter like can you see what i eat you
call me out you're
i'm a fighter i don't give a [ __ ]
i want like i want to go in there and
just [ __ ] you up yeah
as long as i make the weight i don't
have to be do you hold them accountable
or do you guys give me anything
i don't think you're better than me
i i was a bad influence in your life in
vegas
i was a bad influence in her life in
vegas in and out and [ __ ] all the time
oh uh
yeah and then one [ __ ] came over once
the one dude then juan came over after
his fight dude yeah yeah one came over
after his fight and [ __ ] we're like
eating these big ice cream sandwiches
and yeah they're like waffles with ice
cream we had like things this big i was
like for sure
put it this way on the house i was still
watching what i was eating and she was
bringing me food from uh the pi yeah i
was trying my best do they have good
food there
no but healthy food healthy food
i don't any healthy food i don't like
the cafeteria ain't bad no no it's any
healthy food i don't like oh gotcha yeah
i like chicken and like broccoli yeah
you give me some [ __ ] out of my [ __ ]
gold flavor
i'm easy to run to to junk food gotcha
like i was raised on it bro yeah
[ __ ] yeah me too i'm addicted to sugar
[ __ ] top ramen and [ __ ] yeah mac
and cheese yeah yeah mac and cheese
frozen pizzas tortillas
pizza rolls
sugar everything
my son's gonna be [ __ ] when he goes to
school he don't know nothing about that
stuff dude you don't like you're one of
those dads that like he's he's never
seen candy or some [ __ ] he's had a
little bit but not much away from him
yeah bro i mean
i'm on a
you know i mean like if i buy junk food
still like it's not like that much it's
like not really junk food you don't have
like
fruit by the footage no [ __ ] no no way
i've never seen that shot i've got [ __ ]
everywhere
what the [ __ ] is this
here is this [ __ ] [ __ ] soda yeah
soda
what is dr pepper she's amazing
dude yeah all right let me get one i
need your
teachings in my house my kids wake up
i'm like
bro there's ice cream
it's tough
well like henry's get like cause hannah
and eve don't
they're like we got bananas let's go
this kid's fine
when he's 16 he's gonna freak the [ __ ]
out well yeah my kids wake up and
they're like hey like i'm like [ __ ] yeah
i get my kid candy in the morning i'm
like there's uh there's pop rocks yeah i
bought a bunch of pop rocks yeah and i'm
like have some pop rocks right now
it's like for real i was like yeah it's
breakfast dude how's it going this is
brilliant some milk pop rocks you're
good dude and then when i wake up i cook
them food you know but nice yeah but the
yeah i'm the breakfast guy bro i wake up
i i cook up i cook [ __ ]
i don't i don't wake up early it's just
like i like breakfast
it's like if i'm gonna cook something
it's gonna be breakfast like this
weekend it's always breakfast
quit playing uh
all right kids if you haven't aborted
hairy balls it's time to buzz light your
woody with manscape the official
electric trimmer of the ufc
uh get your rocket ready like elon musk
for takeoff with the new lawnmower 4.0
kicker pubes another planet manscape is
taking off it's now available in not
only the usa but canada the uk across
europe australia south africa singapore
it's all over and all the thick boys
tonight get 20 off and free shipping
with the code cfc at manscape.com that's
20 off and free shipping with the code
cfc manscape.com
uh
we'll get 20 from free shipping code cfc
at manscape uh for clean trinity and
beyond your spaceballs well thank you i
gotta get some manscape dude you can
take that one
don't shave your head though dude no
doubt your hair don't shave your head
again no probably never do that again i
gotta give it to my brother bro he's
like 16. he's in that age you know or
like can you impress the women
i'm not going to say nothing because my
mom's probably watching
your brother's good looking guy too oh
my brother my brother's a [ __ ] dime
he's a [ __ ] stud yeah he's stud i've
seen bro that that [ __ ] he's
yeah
yeah i'm he's a cool kid too he's cool
uh but he doesn't
he stayed in vegas with us the whole
time the whole show really he was there
all [ __ ] seven weeks
what would you not want to stay there
you bro he was having fun
he's a good kid man yeah he uh
he's trying to pursue acting actually
good for him yeah
you know like i thought i had good uh
like oh i have blue eyes but you know
when you have no blue eyes and you still
look good yeah
that's how you know you're a
good-looking [ __ ] yeah he's got
that
yeah he's a good-looking kid yeah
main event dear god derek lewis get this
done
hey mark you're coming back
dude
how much you done
what's up how about you down
he's gambling how much down the camera
because he can't get biceps eating
[ __ ] pizza you know what i mean like
he's doing that [ __ ] off camera
you gotta drink whiskey to get biceps
bro protein shake
protein cookie yeah
is that pizza any good from erwin good
[Laughter]
till tomorrow morning i'll leave at 5
a.m
i get up at like 10 o'clock 10 o'clock
nine o'clock holy [ __ ] until your girl
your girl's getting up because that's
like [ __ ] yeah oh yeah i sleep in the
guest room most time oh wow during fight
camp
i like that you're honest about getting
up at nine or ten dude i'm gonna [ __ ]
i train late like my last prank my last
training i start at eight get done at 10
i get home [ __ ] can't sleep don't go
to sleep till like one or two o'clock
you know
so i don't [ __ ] cause mark wahlberg i
got trained at four it's like but you go
to sleep at 6 00 p.m yeah it's like
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] right yes his
kids are like dad we've seen you for
half an hour yeah yeah you're going to
be right away i wake up late as [ __ ]
yeah yeah i do not i wake up at 12.
i know i know that's why you look so
funny look at this guy yeah
depends late you're like two four five
okay like five or if you're a
professional athlete nine ten hours
my training camps like
yeah like when that one like sometimes
they mix like our schedules or he's
training like when he was in camp and
i'm in camp yeah
and they're like oh it's going to be
like maybe the title is going to be a
problem and
these guys are working out by the time i
hit my first session yeah
he's like yeah i'm already on my third
one i'm like what the [ __ ] i'm like bro
it's 12.
i woke up early today to get here like
i woke up at 10 30. tj you're taking don
yeah i got gone gone's too much juvenile
here's the thing you only have 10 fights
yeah but dude he's an athlete
like you gotta think about like so look
i like derrick lewis's power i really do
and i like him as a [ __ ] just like
character
he's great he sells tickets he's [ __ ]
funny but gone is the better fighter
fighter he's smarter yeah like yeah
if derek didn't have that power he'd be
super fun yeah yeah yeah but he goddamn
yeah but he does but he does this thing
he can finish in the late rounds too
yeah you know like yeah like that vote
clap fight he's getting [ __ ] up and
then just oh god
yeah the whole time but i just think
god's footwork's gonna be too much these
crowds can go nuts for uh for [ __ ]
deer clothes
[ __ ] stuff
during the press conference he's like
what do you think if you get beat by a
frenchman in front of your hometown
no that's why i have that thing because
yeah it fits big guys nice fits up to
six yeah the panamera does as well yeah
but the the lambos i don't know how he
does no but there's one that looks like
uh different yeah i love the porsche's
monsters i drove a knife at land eleven
could do throw or do you ever go to that
little app things like go-karts monsters
you ever gone to that place in carson
like up the world
yeah yeah yeah where you can just
[ __ ] it's a racetrack and you just
take porsches yeah i know you can drive
like gt3s and
some turbos but yeah it'd be fun
i pass it all the time and i [ __ ]
never go anywhere
supposed to be pretty dope
your family's still in colorado yeah
nice
nice
come on derek lewis
this fight's about to be real boring
no i'm just giving me a [ __ ] i don't
know but don't jinx he loses i'm pretty
sure somebody's going based off his
walkout right now do you think he looks
nervous or ready so definitely he's
always yeah yeah okay yeah but i
guarantee you he's nervous though yeah
he's fighting in houston bro it's his
hometown yeah
i thought in sacramento that [ __ ] was
[ __ ] ridiculous but i also got more
pressure huh do am i my opponent
switching 24 hour notice oh i was
supposed to fight brow for the second
time after i beat him and he didn't make
weight so i fought joe soto on 24 hours
notice
oh [ __ ] yeah i was [ __ ] like deathly
afraid i remember that i knew how good
the guy was i've trained with him he's a
bellator champion
no one knew who he was i took that i
took the final 24-hour notice like
if i would have lost to him i was ever
like oh this guy's a [ __ ] joke yeah
you know i was awesome
for the title he survived longer than
expected right
from what he sort of survived longer
huh
yeah that's what it was because everyone
was like dance [ __ ] survived
long like he was it was awesome he gave
me some good right hands for the [ __ ]
duralast battery yeah in a situation
like that do they put pressure on you to
accept the fight like or do you is there
any part of you that's like i don't know
yeah i got this phone call like look
champ we need you to take this bro yeah
so that right up front we'll take care
of you we need you to take this did they
take care of you no do you write
no
i love them i've heard this story so
many times it's [ __ ] great my
favorite my favorite is chris weidman we
took defying late notice stuff i think
it was i got one i got zero dollar bonus
40 pounds he like topped 40 pounds like
eight days he's like at least they're
taking care of me fights maya and he's
like dude what the [ __ ] they're like
yeah you're good dude yeah cause then dc
tells the story where he lost to jon
jones and they sent him like a million
dollar check or something do you know
that story yeah i've heard that story
i've heard it but happened to shane
collins i think he's making it up
i don't i don't know that's the case i
[ __ ] get my ass
interesting round number you came up
with you would but i mean if you think
about it say that now but you wouldn't
argue about it they've taken care of
beyond you wouldn't do it like he's got
so many gigs doing you think so
obviously they like him oh yeah yeah
he's too prideful bro [ __ ] yeah
then if you win it's worth more than a
million for sure you know what i mean no
not my next one i'm saying like a fight
like a fight ever if they're willing to
pay you a million dollars to lose
it's worth
five times and that's fine
you know yeah no dude i've been fighting
for a while now you have to get a
million-dollar paycheck
well you beat volkanovsky you're gonna
not this time but that's what you said
but if they were like
hey bro
[ __ ] no no no no no [ __ ] that
for a million and then i can still keep
stay at the top like [ __ ] it
no way
did you go practice my acting you know
yeah
yeah you got to get your ass kicked in
the movie all right let me do it for
real that's right he's a real method
actor
damn dance lost some weight yeah he has
right i was thinking the same thing or
he's wearing a triple xl shirt
since they're just hanging off and spanx
derek's lost weight too yeah i like he's
like no you won't he's got he's got 20
pounds to make it
265 though yeah because he's still
crazy this guy there's been a couple
guys that had to cut 65. crazy why would
you get a tattoo like that on your chest
which one
[ __ ]
you talking about his god smack that
dude
bring up the godsmack logo
are you doing i can get behind this
right here i get behind this dude that's
a deep cut to god smack this some of
this one right here what is this that's
a tattoo that's got smack that's almost
as bad as the [ __ ] dick in the chest
from car what's not car with the [ __ ]
hammer the sword jesus
do you know that band
what was their key song chin
they had some slappers back in the day
moon baby was one of them
i don't you would know how much baby
he knew it right away you said gossip
was there to either moon
got you you had it
ah stand alone real that's cool keep
away unforgettable bullet proof
what's this what's this tattoo say knock
out what
minus 350 at heavyweight somebody's
always got to go
i didn't know
know aside from being like america
versus france this is also like a
light-skinned dark-skinned war
i'm just like that's right that's right
in the race
oh [ __ ] it took that part i think i just
know a lot of people
it is interesting he used to train with
i realized you're just here to stir the
pot
you're really here just to stir the
[ __ ] trolls i love it
i love it
[ __ ] it
come on there no small person in the
back right corner is that who's that
girl
that's a girl
he's a girl but i think that's just one
of his trainers
oh yeah female trainer
[ __ ] no strength and conditioning i
think oh yeah strength and conditioning
yeah i can see it oh jack
like cool awesome i mean he possesses
knockout power so she's doing something
right
this guy
come on dick i do i do love him i want
him to win just because boxing is
terrible but yeah i just want to [ __ ]
come on
i would what size glove do you think he
had to make for him size 5x i i don't
think his hands are that big he's not
like francis or shin cartoons
yeah right it was a [ __ ] seven eggs
he's my wrestling coach in colorado
and we were doing some fishing on the
lake and we were drinking beer hanging
out on his boat and uh like hey shane
you need a beer he's like no i got one
he's got it in his hand like this looks
like you can't see it because it's
holding like this it looks like those
mini coats you can't see his beard he's
like no i got a bomb oh [ __ ] they did
the same [ __ ] with uh
remember the documentary they did on
audrey the giant yeah yeah and he was
like he looks like he has
one of those 22 ounce [ __ ] these
couples
the giant though yeah shane the almost a
giant come on derek
here we go i i bet he's just gonna blitz
his ass early on he's gonna sit back and
get he's loading up that right he's i
think he's just sit back though yeah and
he said he's gonna sit down he fight
interviews that's what he said he's not
coming after him he's not going around
you can kind of come after gone though
because he doesn't really knock dude oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ]
he threw a head kick damn he got his
foot up there too i was about to say
that that was one of those
that's like one of the craziest things
i've ever seen was dc throw a [ __ ]
head kick right you see a guy that looks
like kung fu panda yeah just throwing
[ __ ] head kicks and derek luke just
threw one i love this champion
i love it man
i love it i can't on see that got smack
tattoo on god's chest
it is tragic the tattoo down his spine
reminds me of the angelina jolie tattoo
on her back
dude that's the least of my [ __ ] stop
turning me on dude
oh [ __ ]
come on d tomb raider yeah his footwork
is filthy dude
nah he's gonna let's catch him yeah
yeah god's gonna get a little too cocky
and no way bro i don't don is kind of i
think they're
no
hands are down he's already kind of like
oh okay you're not doing anything thank
you guys you're not seeing any of
derrick lewis's [ __ ] fights you know
do [ __ ] for [ __ ] 14 minutes it just
knocks you out i wouldn't i wouldn't
mind if uh derek did a blast double on
his ass either oh that'd be funny
he doesn't like it i'm telling you right
now if if something happens and derek
lewis stands on the top he's gonna knock
him out agree he'll ground
probably the best in the game yeah it's
good has that like bigger version of
fedor yeah i think he has the most
knockouts via ground power oh doubt it
come on here's the thing guys
we can get five rounds of this that's
what i'm saying moose doesn't knock him
out you're getting this for a five
[ __ ] rounds oh like we got down the
controllers he just pulled it john jones
turned his back and ran
[ __ ] on his bike
oh [ __ ]
i'm pretty sure this week you're gonna
get though
i don't know tj oh i think i think in
the last minute of every round i think
derek looks gonna explode he's gonna be
like all right i'm good [ __ ]
come back john's just piecing them up
right now
not much going on nothing nothing's
really general he's only landed one
thing if i'm gained and i'm a smart
[ __ ] fighter
stick his leg
[Music]
[Laughter]
he don't want to wrestle no who wants to
wrestle
no one no one wants to [ __ ] wrestle
him i know how to wrestle i don't want
to wrestle yeah
i [ __ ] hate it
especially it would be interesting if
john jones fought as you get older it's
worse they do hurt it's horrible she
hurts it's a lot of energy
it's like [ __ ] wrestling aspect
that's what goes through your mind right
when you don't get it you're like [ __ ]
you're like oh you killed him in the
nuts
it would be interesting if john fought a
heavyweight to see him and gone go at it
because john can match him
technique-wise yeah yeah and he's in his
reach yeah my balls but outside john
nobody's gonna [ __ ] with him oh yeah
clip the dick just got the tip but dude
all you got was the tip every time i've
been kicked in the balls it should never
hurt it doesn't what do you wear
i wear a steel cup i wear like the
[ __ ] big five one
i just
i just look at my chances of really
getting hit
it only takes one time
[ __ ] that from the last cup i have no
idea
that's why my ass don't surf man it only
takes one time for a shark to get you oh
no
right i'm like [ __ ] i want to learn how
to surf every time
i'm always like [ __ ]
i've been out there a couple of times
i'm like [ __ ] this is horrible just i
feel paranoid the whole time i was out
there
looking around
oh
look at him running look at him running
smiling why are you running dog
come on let's go let's fight he's
smarter get him derek
he ain't no he's kind of playing the
game though a little bit he's gonna be
playing with fighters you can get caught
up ufc ufc man that they can god please
lose please lose
i mean derrick that's the closest come
to landing when he turned his back
there's gonna be like he's okay
body is the easiest thing to go on
derrick right
yeah he took remember he got hurt a lot
from volkov yeah with the to the body
yep a little tokyo oh
she brought left kick after oh god doug
it's not looking good
no it's looking
was like that's a punch dog
yeah it's not looking good for d
no all right not good not my eye damn
yeah i think it was the yeah
boom we have [ __ ] right
when you're like training and the
[ __ ] glove really touches you and
you're like mother screams yeah
hardly touches you
yeah i really get punched like full on
then like
just rather get hit full-on like
sometimes like i hit like a little light
touch and like i'm like [ __ ]
it's like a paper cut right yeah it just
feels weird nothing worse than just that
it feels like the eyes of the glove
across like your eyelid it's [ __ ]
horrible
yeah or if you catch the laces at all
like the laces on the other side you
round for gone huh yeah
yeah yeah one zero but i feel like uh
well at least like jericho is showing up
derrick lewis
he's fighting in [ __ ] houston
he's fighting for the title yep he said
he worked out more he's never worked out
his entire life like people don't do
that unless you're nervous yeah you're
right you know like i'm gonna go work
out way more than i've ever worked on my
life until i'm nervous yep you know yep
come on d
bro you've been talking up game i know
well this is why he's [ __ ] good
i just figured in the hometown dick
lewis throw caution in the wind maybe
land something he'll get there you got
five rounds
i don't know dude in the second round
the longer it goes the least chances
yeah
but honestly like the way i looked at it
right now uh
when you look at him in the corner derek
wasn't breathing yeah he you that's a
good point he wasn't breathing that hard
he was just like
well good then [ __ ] and the other guy
was like
it's just oh he needs to stop those kids
i love it though oh
that worked though what were you saying
though where was it
what were you saying to stop the kids
i'm saying that headquarters yeah it's
because god's too talented it's not
going to work on this guy watch that
[ __ ] come on watch them
gonna be amazing
so no matter who wins this francis is
gonna have to fight the winner that's
what's kind of dope about intern belts
there's no you have no choice dude
you're gonna have to fight the guy yeah
what's the deal with francis why he goes
down the problem with the contract yeah
he has one fight left on his contract he
wants he wants more money to fight jones
yeah
what's your own blame makes the [ __ ]
bad man on the planet yeah makes
sense [ __ ] i like the ufc's like
we're not playing john or francis so
it's like you guys wanna yeah because
they already got the deal with espn oh
what was that
come on d
yeah i hear a lot about that about like
the negotiating power that they have
with these fighters
we don't need to sell pay-per-views they
have oh oh oh they have the power
because of the espn deal yeah that
basically took all the they don't have
stars yeah they don't need stars anymore
yeah they could just filled you [ __ ]
and then it doesn't matter they still
get paid yeah they don't care
yeah
once that deal got signed it just took
all the bargaining rights away from the
fighters yeah
he's gotta win
yes yeah come on you gotta [ __ ] win
bro that's a good body but that's an
awesome
it's not just the ufc it's everything
you if you're scared if you don't win
you're not gonna get paid yeah yeah yeah
i mean that's i've said that for years
man winning solves everything just keep
winning and you guys guys are there
there's guys that can lose and keep
getting paid but connor you're not one
of those guys yeah yeah just just nick
you know
yeah i wasn't afraid to see apollo cost
it was like i'm not fighting because i'm
not getting paid enough and then he gets
a hair transplant yeah
he's also a guy that the ufc was like
cool man right right yeah he
overestimates his value is like there's
very few guys who can pull that your
potential to be a star but you just got
your ass beat
man if we get four more rounds this i'll
be pissed
i'm telling you
uh it only takes a split yeah he's too
good heavy weights man it's only take a
split second
do you think it's any different with
francis he does francis
no i think francis pieces him up
france is a little more dangerous
because he's explosive he's good too
he's more explosive but i still think
game beats him dude yeah i do
yeah he's a better average what you're
saying though is you're single you're
saying that again you're saying that
gone could beat stipe
no yeah see there you go that's
but he beats francis yeah but ain't
gonna beat nobody foreign
i don't think anybody beats god i could
be honest if he fights like this
i think stephen beats him god this would
be the worst thought
you could have as a champion
gosh
landing right heavily
and this way he's gonna fight yeah i am
not watching he's grinding wrestling
pictures no you don't get it ufc does
not want a french guy as a champion that
fights like this i'm sure they i kind of
think they do they want to go to france
money they don't no yeah they want
houston
they can't sell this they want d lewis
to knock him out and fight francis balls
are hot yeah yeah i mean like
like derek's markable yeah he is he's
how do you describe his style josh
who's gone yeah he's well-rounded man
he's probably he's probably the most
well-rounded heavyweights he's the best
athlete in the division
i don't think john's a better athlete
than god
uh you know john john ran a 4-9 in the
40s sir
what does that mean i'm just
bonded or john john okay i'm just saying
like athletics do you think gone can run
faster than that i think i think brendan
did like a four six correct but
well i'm really running four five three
four six yeah i'm holding five pounds no
big deal but i'm just
that's actually really [ __ ] fast bro
had a cappuccino with buffalo bills
anyways so
but i'm just saying that's actually
really [ __ ] fast i'm just saying like
athletically explosive i think god's
more explosive like john don't have
knockout power
i agree you're talking okay so who's the
better athlete though is what you're
saying but john's the better fighter
like just because you're a good athlete
doesn't mean you're great so wait are we
judging after being the best athlete
because you can run a 40 faster and you
can do more pull-ups jump is that where
you're at faster more explosive better
times other sports faster i think
especially at heavyweight faster than
john i don't know man i think
i think we underestimated john right now
i think john's a better fighter yeah and
that includes like the creativity that
creativity wrestling
yeah how he mixes it up yeah his iq is
fine he's not saying like his single
[ __ ] like the way he chooses single
shots like a single strike versus a
single stick and like like you just
don't know what's coming he's the
highest iq in the ufc i think john does
best fight iq in the game
no
yeah i mean yeah i would have said it
could be but we had a straight up just
this was his iq
iq the [ __ ] i take you down yeah
that's that's honest that's the best iq
he never changed most fighters would
want to change their iq too that's all
you can do though for fans think about
john he has to wrestle yeah strike hit
he has to figure the guy out and then
after that first round john usually
takes over yeah
i thought it was like i'm gonna take you
down if you're saying
here's the thing it's hard for me to
judge that based off because
jon jones we don't know when he can box
trump he's both there's both his
brothers in the nfl i'm sure they can
jump high i'm sure they can run faster
and i'm sure
they're better athletes the apple didn't
fall far from the tree yeah so
if he was this good of an athlete why is
he not in the nfl why is he not doing
all those other things he's from france
dude
that's so funny you know like friendship
like football
yeah he's a giant dude in france man
that's what he decided to do oh man
but yes john would be the better fighter
so what are you saying about french
people
is that what we're doing they're not
interested
they're generally not tough you know
yeah you know what most koreans are not
sticks too
there's some big [ __ ] koreans
oh yes most koreans are pronounced 16.
yeah they're not no no
yeah ginger the biggest group did you
did you watch do you listen to rogan's
last show with that uh jaomi
park yes good god i saw the highlights i
was like oh i don't want to cut my
[ __ ] throat oh my gosh man i just saw
some of the clips about people eating
kids or something oh my god testing's
falling out of them no i don't know i
don't know he doesn't fall out of her
body and like still begging for i love
north korea oh my gosh that's one of my
favorites
i love learning about north korea
i'm all sad i'm all about it man i'm
podcast at least four times oh you're a
psychopath i [ __ ] love it man i'm
like this is crazy to think what's my
weird obsession just to think of like
all the [ __ ] that's going on there and
people like oh wow
her mom said that she was not telling
the truth her mom's probably afraid for
her life yeah homeboy just killed his
[ __ ] brother and his uncle yeah for
power that stuff's too dark man jesus
man
imagine if you're korean oh god and was
it was it three hours of her talking
about that yeah stressing three and a
half almost like three twenty set damn
it's like watching schindler's list
every day dude yeah i'm out i thought
you were saying like the thing about her
though watching her like talk about it
is she's she's pretty hot so yeah she is
attractive yeah
which helps but
i mean looks aren't everything i was
listening to the car so i didn't really
get to see it but
no oh there goes that elbow
oh if he ends up on the bottom if he
ends up on bottom ah come on there
killer
leg
that's a good point
he tried against matriarch he got
knocked out oh oh foot sweep
almost got him he needs to [ __ ] just
go yes you're going to lose yeah you're
going to sit back and he's weird he's
going to be like too worried yeah too
[ __ ] nervous
he ain't going to finish houston houston
seconds before you judge what's going to
happen
i guarantee you going this round this
team's like dude you got to get going
here we got paul in the front what's the
worst can happen you just [ __ ] go you
get knocked out lately at least you're
going to lose watching oh he's trying
he's kind of trying
yeah
that one hurt the difference in that
kick versus the first round where he was
just kind of tapping him yeah i think
it's gonna affect that kid
you noticed god hasn't been [ __ ] whoa
oh [ __ ] god it's around trouble it's a
rap it's a wrap
ten he gave up
yeah he's not fighting back back throw
back six he's fight back now all right
there we go like your best chances to
fight back but sometimes this one oh
well slick that was slick yeah and god
hasn't really been [ __ ] touched dude
at all get him dick oh i even touch it
all
right what is easy [ __ ] close to it
what do you think it's a wrap here or no
not yet it's close
very close but sometimes derek a land
when what was that mouthpiece oh my god
that was slick
oh that hit him in the face
see but this is when derek knocks out
when you're trained like this he's all
tired yeah oh
yeah i'm telling you that
he's going to stop it they're going down
yeah he did he wanted out
well that's a shame
damn it son
tj did you bet no [ __ ] no no he's like
no you should have yeah he called it i
know are you guys allowed to bet on the
ufc fights yeah you're right i don't
even know yeah you can't get better
yourself i don't think you've been
understanding you're better than
yourself and you can bet other people's
fights yeah you can better yourself
you can't just bet your opponent's gonna
win yeah
you can bet on yourself yeah because
that one that one kid bound himself met
his whole person and lost everything
he lost split decision to it yeah
[ __ ]
dude i [ __ ] put up
and then
no i'm saying like i keep talking about
that though oh yeah justin james i'm
saying like has no regrets
i don't mean it like that [ __ ] yeah it's
like a come up
yeah he bet 25k on himself that was just
yeah that's a bummer
god derrick lewis looked really really
bad he didn't do nothing and then he
looked like you're nervous yeah he was
the hometown he's too nervous dude too
much pressure like that pressure you
can't [ __ ] handle sometimes you know
like it's so much easier when there's
not that much light on you but when
there's that much [ __ ] light
championship [ __ ] fights dealing with
the [ __ ] media fighting your hometown
here's the thing donald
donald francis man that god doesn't get
[ __ ] hit dude yeah
yeah so they're going to be stipe and
jon jones
well
done no yeah they got to pay john so
okay so if they don't get it done i hope
they get it done i like to see god and
jon jones
that's a fight that [ __ ] t-shirt
feels like a rash card
oh my god snug [ __ ] medium super snug
so that happens it'll be gone jones
no next is gone francis yeah for sure i
just wanted to make the pun
videos but but do you know what the
thing is is francis doesn't sign that
contract that they're asking you're
gonna get john jones i bet what do you
think the president is gonna look like
now with him like this yeah can you do
what do you do with gun
gone sepe gone stipe fight for the
interim because he see god's gonna
already be the interim champ right now
if john jones wants it if france if yeah
john johnson so then cb automatically
gets his title shot right which is what
he wants yeah which is what he wants
because he was the interview started
going to one championship or something
just like yeah you know the ufc contract
worked yeah but he the thing is he was
on his last fight for his contract it
sends you two more fights but every time
you fight for the title if you're the
champ every time you defend your title
it sends you two more fights that's
dirty yeah
i think it's a bell tour thing i don't
think it's a no you have to see it for
sure hundred percent are you mixing up
here we're gonna have five champions in
new york
yeah i don't know yeah you're right i
don't know if you're extending your your
contract extends every time you defend
your title for two fights yeah it's in
your is there a dilla shark claws
that shirt is so tight down to your
point right that shirt is well it's a
[ __ ] shirt yeah it's cutting off his
back
dc used to be heavyweight this guy's big
he's [ __ ] he's tall yeah
yeah but this ain't that big either is
he calling anybody out is anybody
listening in here
he's listening is he calling you he's
just talking bad english
you probably can't show the volume on
here no no so i have to guess yeah like
we had cody garbrandt on sugar shawn
called him out yeah and i was like man
can you imagine sean called you out they
were like bullshitting that's all i was
like dude
i think it's a bad fight for cody
sugar's athletic yeah i really do i
think it's a bad fight but it's not
happening because cody's fighting uh
it's good i do cody's small man cody's
fight yeah yeah yeah
yeah his last fight he walked into the
cage 142 pounds yep
yes you told me you weighed in 136 and
walking 142 like yeah i thought 125s and
walked in 152. yep yeah like yeah that's
wild yeah i think they they uh confirmed
he's fighting france i think yeah they
did which is a tough fight dude yeah
that's what i but that was my whole
point like dude fight sugar
again tough fight but everybody knows
sugar yeah france a lot more than one
you can fight a lot more to win yeah
dude yeah but everybody knows sugar yeah
no
well is that it kids has he called
anybody out nothing he's not my friend
him and france is our friend so i doubt
he talks [ __ ] anything casey taking his
team
he's snaking this team
yeah that whole time the whole time
right i'll say the same [ __ ]
that's awesome i'll tell you you could
give gon fritz in his heyday it would be
dc
yeah cause he couldn't beat him down
yeah i think he beat him now
he beat him yeah built built like a
[ __ ] armadillo i think you should be
mounted on the couch built like an
armadillo
hey bro what's going on with your suits
like bro i can't wear a tie anymore
next too i get my neck's too big i can't
wear it anymore none of my shirts
[ __ ] hate me i can't button the top
button so hard it's so great there's no
oh dc would break him i don't think
right now dc needs a eight month
training dc's 44 years 43 years old four
months 42 20
yeah that's just too much he'd be
stylish
is interesting though as you're saying
that's a good thing that's that that
gives you exactly what he wants he can
fight for the title next he wants that
fight if that make you the interim
champion you're guaranteed to be next
until francis or jon jones i think he
really wants that john jones fight
because that fight will make him more
money than he's made in all of his other
fights steve john's offense yeah i think
and he's not having it right they're
friends that's the other problem they're
friends dc trying to stand up for
francis is that like yeah that's the
fight like let's do it pretty much well
it's got to be the fight right you're
the inner choice yeah you have to fight
the champions although francis with that
contract francophones stick together
i mean if you're the interim champion
you fight the champion there's no other
choice well you sound like there was
another i can't remember whether yeah
you know
that one in our championship i'm the
fake champion you know he had to defend
our title a couple times you can defend
your internal championship your fake
championship no but i'm gonna defend my
fake championship
there was another weight class i can't
remember who it was but they had they
had the interim yeah someone it was i
think it was highway yeah yeah there was
an interim champion the interim
championship is a [ __ ] joke though
right i mean let's be honest like you
have to fight the champion though true
well not everyone's been a multiple what
happens if the champion never comes back
what happens
[ __ ] tyson fury well then you're the
champion correct you're not the interim
no more yeah i get what you're saying
but like like if you're the interim
champion you're kind of like it's like
saying like i think the internet fake
champion the interim used to have some
value to it now they do it and i feel
over time it lost its value yeah yeah
because i'll throw it into seller yeah
well now they do it to press the you
know yeah oh it's selling reviews
they'll fight this guy yeah the only way
they'll know where to get the comments
i'll pay for it yeah
all right is that it kids
that's it
daddy to thank you thank you holding the
fort down i've always wanted to say chin
to pull that up for me please good
[ __ ] appreciate that i never want to
be that guy bring that [ __ ] up
hold up
it's [ __ ] great
well we love you guys what do we got for
you i'm in north carolina august 19th
through 21st north carolina and then end
of the month i'm at la jolla comedy
store
was that august 26 28 that's a thursday
friday saturday la jolla california
tommy store san jose's september 9th
through 11th take it to
fatkz.com or thickboy.com uh thank you
guys for doing this man love you guys
september 9th yes question
san jose oh that's right you'll be let's
go that's [ __ ] that's [ __ ] good
i've got some friends going too from the
barrier yeah oh yeah you're from there
too that's [ __ ] next fight companion
calves fighting september 17th is uh
bellator and strikeforce or sorry
bellator in san jose also oh damn so i
think big john will be in town when
you're doing your show oh that'd be fun
uh next uh fight campaign will be before
the 29th jake paul woodley have a great
lineup all right love you guys thanks
for watching
not the best card
you